mes chers collègues je propose de
commencer nos travaux en préalable de
cette audition nous devons nommer un
rapporteur un rapporteur sur la
recevabilité de la proposition de
résolution tendance à la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur les causes de
l'incapacité de la France à atteindre
les objectifs des plans successifs de
maîtrise des impacts des produits
phytosanitaires sur la santé humaine et
environnementale et notamment sur les
conditions de l'exercice des missions
des autorités publiques en charge de la
sécurité
sanitaire je rappelle qu'il s'agit d'une
proposition présentée par le groupe
socialiste dans le cadre de son droit de
tirage j'ai reçu la candidature de
Monsieur Dominique potier y a-t-il des
oppositions
il n'y a pas d'opposition il en est
ainsi décidé mes chers collègues nous en
venons maintenant à l'audition qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui pour échanger sur le
thème important de l'avenir des
concessions d'autoroute avec Philippe
Noury président du groupe
apr area Monsieur Pierre Copé président
de Vinci Autoroutes et Monsieur Arnaud
Kemar directeur général du groupe
SANEF messieurs je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation elle fait suite
sur le même sujet aux auditions des
ministres Clément bonne et Bruno Bruno
Le Maire ainsi que Monsieur Philippe
Richard président par intérim de la RT
l'agence de régulation des transports
votre audition s'inscrit aussi dans le
cadre plus large de nos travaux sur les
infrastructures dédiées aux mobilité du
quotidien dont les autoroutes font
partie pour certains de nos concitoyens
une volonté de travailler aussi sur le
verdissement de ces autoroutes mais
aussi puisque c'est venu dans le cadre
de la proposition de loi que j'ai porté
et je remercie de votre investissement
chers collègues des services express
régionaux métropolitain puisque les
collègues ont demandé que les
concessionnaires d'autoroute fassent
partie de la concertation dans
l'élaboration de ces services express
régionaux métropolitain dans ce cadre il
est évident et évidemment incontournable
de vous entendre puisque vous dirigez
les trois principales sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes notre
commission et naturellement très
impliqué dans la question du modèle
autoroutier que nous souhaitons pour
demain alors que les concessions vont à
plus ou moins long terme arriver à
l'heure termes nos auditions l'ont
montré le modèle est le modèle actuel
est sur certains points perfectibles il
n'est pas
inutile d'envisager un certain nombre
d'évolution en particulier le sujet de
l'équilibre des contrats qui lient
l'État aux sociétés d'autoroute
suscitent des interrogations sur leur
durée sur la rétribution des
concessionnaires donc la rentabilité
peut parfois faire débat mais aussi sur
le niveau des tarifs de péage ou encore
le contrôle exercer par l'État en tant
que représentant de la nation nous avons
à coeur de préserver vous l'avez compris
les intérêts de l'État qui sont ceux de
nos concitoyens tout en nous assurant
que les autoroutes sont bien entretenues
et qu'elles permettront de relever un
défi essentiel qui est le défi de la
transition énergétique dans les
transports
car de nouveaux services devront être
déployés en particulier pour faire face
à l'essor des véhicules électriques le
déploiement des voies réservées et cela
nécessitera forcément des
investissements messieurs nous sommes
donc intéressés par vos analyses sur
tous ces sujets et je vous souhaite donc
la parole pour un propos liminaire d'une
vingtaine de minutes et puis nous
passerons ensuite aux échanges avec les
députés messieurs la parole est à vous
merci monsieur le Président
pour cet accueil nous sommes
concessionnaires de l'État et à ce titre
très heureux d'avoir l'occasion de
participer à cette commission et à cette
échange nous nous sommes répartis
les présentations avec Arnaud Kemar
directeur général de SANEF et Philippe
Nouri qui est le patron de la P2R et je
suis moi-même le patron de Vinci
Autoroutes qui
notamment à SF Koffi route et Escota je
le disais nous venons avec plaisir
participé à cette audition notamment
parce qu'il se dit beaucoup de choses
inexactes sur les concessions
d'autoroute mais aussi parce que la
question de la route est essentielle
pour nos concitoyens et pour les
finances publiques au regard des
investissements nécessaires qui vont qui
ne peuvent que croître en particulier du
fait de la nécessité de décarboner les
déplacements mais aussi
des ressources collectées sur la
mobilité routière qui elles sont
appelées diminuées si rien n'est fait
je souhaiterais tout d'abord rappeler ce
que sont les concessions d'autoroute
parmi les infrastructures du pays ainsi
si vous me le permettez que leur modèle
économique le réseau routier national
avant la mise en œuvre de la loi 3DS au
premier janvier prochain représente
20910 km
sur plus d'un million de kilomètres de
route que contre le pays
les autoroutes représentent environ 1%
de ce réseau
12619 km pour être précis dont 9310 sont
concédés 1% des kilomètres du réseau
routier donc sont concédés mais 30% des
distances parcourues le son sur
autoroute le réseau concédé comporte un
patrimoine considérable 42000 km de
voies
13100 ouvrages d'art 364
de service 631 aires de repos 174
parking de covoiturage et
1852 passage pour la faune c'est le
patrimoine que nous avons construit
c'est le patrimoine que nous exploitons
et que nous gérons et j'y ajoute une
soixantaine de tunnels qui et graines
l'ensemble de nos réseaux il y en a 33
sur le réseau Vinci autoroute je sais
pas combien il y en a sur le réseau a
P2R ce réseau est exploité par 20
sociétés les trois groupes que nous
représentons ici VINCI Autoroutes à
p2rsanef et leur filiales trois
concessionnaires publics ne les oublions
pas les autoroutes et le tunnel du
Mont-Blanc sftr pour le tunnel du Fréjus
et la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
de la scène des concessionnaires
indépendants des grands groupes que sont
Atland Alice Alba et Licorne atosca et
trois sociétés exploitantes pour
la 88 et la 63 ainsi que pour la rocade
L2 de Marseille monsieur le Président
les contrats passés entre l'État et ses
sociétés sont des contrats de très long
terme
et leurs échéances s'étale entre 2031 et
2086 si vous avez devant vous les
représentants des principales
concessions historiques auxquelles il
faudrait ajouter les sociétés publiques
dont je viens de parler force de
constater que les contrats passés par
l'État depuis 2000 c'est-à-dire depuis
la fin de la doucement sont également un
des contrats très long 55 ans pour le
contournement ouest de Strasbourg ou
encore 65 ans pour Harcourt les contrats
sont longs car les investissements pour
réaliser exploiter financer entretenir
une autoroute son colossaux et qu'il
faut du temps pour amortir ses
investissements
le modèle des concessions je le disais
d'emblée est souvent mal compris et fait
l'objet de polémique qui sont toutes
liées à une més interprétations de leur
fonctionnement les contrats ont été
conçus dès leur origine pour assurer le
financement de long terme garantissant
la qualité de service et le bon
fonctionnement de l'infrastructure sur
le plan financier la concession finance
sur plusieurs décennies le coût de
construction d'exploitation et de
maintenance et
ceci se fait naturellement grâce au
péage qui a le mérite d'être acquitté
par l'ensemble des
usagers contrairement à l'impôt et c'est
un point à noter et à souligner dans un
pays aussi traversé que la France les
concessions autoroutières présentes une
courbe en J des flux financiers qui
traduit le fait que qui font propres et
une dette importante sont mobilisées dès
les premiers mois pour réaliser des
travaux le remboursement de la dette des
fonds propres le paiement des frais
financiers et la rémunération de
l'immobilisation des fonds propres sont
assurés par le produit des péages sur
toute la durée du contrat pendant les
premières années de la concession le
poids de la dette et la faiblesse des
premiers péages ne permet pas de dégager
des flux de trésorerie positif je le dis
ici une société commerciale classique ne
pourrait pas survivre à une telle
trajectoire économique en étant en
déficit pendant une vingtaine d'années
et très souvent nous sommes
face à des incompréhensions liés au fait
que nos modèles sont comparés à des
sociétés commerciales les contrats de
concession ne sont pas des modèles
économiques
qui ressemble aux sociétés commerciales
ce sont des modèles bien particuliers je
pourrais citer l'exemple de la société
Harcourt dont Vinci est concessionnaire
depuis 2005 et qui gère la concession de
l'autoroute à 19 entre hurtenay et
Courtney nous n'avons plus à purée le
report à nouveau négatif lié aux
exercices déficitaires qu'à partir de
2022 2005 2022 nous n'avons fait que
creuser des dettes alors on nous parle
souvent des dividendes des sociétés
concessionnaires ils sont élevés ils
sont élevés aujourd'hui parce que ça
correspond à la phase de maturité de la
société concessionnelle et qu'il
correspondent d'abord et avant tout au
remboursement des capitaux investis plus
qu'à leur rémunération contrairement à
ce qu'on lit souvent en effet
l'infrastructure concédée est en remise
gratuitement à la fin de la concession à
l'état il convient que les fonds propres
aient été remboursés à ce moment-là la
concession est un contrat à durée
déterminée et ne doit pas être assuré
analyser comme une société commerciale
traditionnelle la courbe engie c'est
beaucoup d'investissement beaucoup de
pertes et beaucoup de dettes au début et
c'est ensuite un montant équivalent de
recettes et de dividendes qui permettent
de rembourser les investissements sur la
durée le problème est qu'on oublie bien
souvent au moment où on les rembourse
les investissements quand ils ont été
consentis
la société et la concession est passée
au risque éperils du concessionnaire
c'est lui qui supporte les aléas temps
positifs que négatifs liés au trafic aux
travaux autour d'intérêt aux risques de
financement ou encore sur les charges
d'exploitation dans la limite des
jurisprudences existantes notamment
celle du fait du prince ou de la théorie
de l'imprévision les résultats que nous
faisons aujourd'hui sont très élevés
compte tenu de la maturité de nos
concessions mais ils sont inférieurs au
plan d'affaires et inférieur aux
prévisions des business models et nous
avons au cours de la période récente
essuyer de très nombreux aléas le covid
n'étant pas le dernier et chacun autour
de cette table le sait je souhaiterais
également
dire un mot de l'importance de la route
dans notre pays d'abord du côté des
parts modèles la route représentée en
2019 87% des déplacements de personnes
en France et cette part est stable
depuis 30 ans elle était de 88 % en 1990
concernant les déplacements de
marchandises de fret la part de la route
en 2021 était de 85% et c'est un chiffre
qui n'a cessé de croître depuis que les
statistiques publiques existent la part
de la route n'était en matière de fret
que de 58% en 1984 j'ajoute et chacun
ici le constat je crois que trois
déplacements domicile travail sur 4
empreinte la route faute d'alternative
en transport en commun
du côté maintenant des infrastructures
dans des investissements pardon dans les
infrastructures de transport ils sont
globalement constants en Europe constant
depuis
1990 ils étaient de 14 milliards en 1990
par an mais il baisse en proportion du
PIB pour ne représenter que 0,97 en 2021
là où il représentait 1,25% du PIB en
1990 ce qui signifie une baisse relative
de plus de 20%. ils ont été fortement
réorientés depuis quelques années au
détriment de la route qui de 65% des
investissements en tendance de long
terme et passer à 45%. c'est 20% d'écart
ont globalement été transférés vers les
transports urbains pour 17%, qui sont
passés de 11 à 29% de part dans les
investissements ou vers le réseau ferré
principal dont la part dans les
investissements est passé de 15 à 19
or ces deux modes de déplacement ne
représentaient en 2019 que 4 et 9% des
kilomètres passagers du côté de la
recette du côté des recettes de
transport je tiens à souligner ici que
la route est très fortement
contributrice au budget public le
rendement de la TICPE est au global
chacun le CIC de 33 milliards d'euros
avant les années récentes qui ont été
perturbées pour diverses raisons et
avant les tendances liées à
l'électrification du parc le produit des
péages autoroutier était en 2021
d'environ 12 milliards et demi dont 4
milliards 7 de taxes soient prête de 40%
de la fiscalité je le redis ici le pH
autoroutier est l'assiette d'une
fiscalité considérable et la route et
l'autoroute financent le fait le péage
autoroutier collecte près de 5 milliards
d'euros de recettes pour l'État et je
pense que c'est important que la
représentation nationale le sache elle
le sait et qu'elle le dise puisque les
concessionnaires autoroutiers lorsqu'on
leur reproche leur reproche le montant
des péages oublient souvent de rappeler
que ces pH sont l'assiette d'une
fiscalité considérable la part hors
fiscalité des péages autoroutiers est
intégralement utilisé au financement des
infrastructures autoroutières la part
fiscale abonde quant à elle le budget
général mais elle est aussi pour partie
fléchés à hauteur d'environ un milliard
d'euros vers d'autres infrastructures de
transport via l'affectation de la
redevance de manielle et de la taxe
d'Amélie nagement du territoire au
budget de l'Agence pour le financement
des infrastructures de transport de
France l'enjeu majeur des politiques de
transport pour les décennies à venir et
la décarbonation des déplacements et la
route étant aujourd'hui
ultra majoritaire dans le transport et
dans le mix des transports elle restera
le mode de déplacement principal de nos
concitoyens pour décarboner les
mobilités il faut donc décarboner la
route Arnaud Kemar il reviendra tout à
l'heure plus en détail mais je laisse
maintenant la parole à mon collègue
nourrit qui doit d'abord évoquer la
question de la rentabilité des
concessions d'autoroute je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vous remercie
de nous donner la parole aujourd'hui
dans un contexte où le modèle
autoroutier fait beaucoup parler de lui
Pierre Copé la rappeler à juste titre la
concession autoroutière est un mode de
gestion des services publics qui a
largement fait ses preuves il suffit de
voir la qualité du réseau autoroutier
français de loin le meilleur d'Europe et
tout cela sans aucun financement public
et même en abondant de manière
significative le budget de l'État pire
Copé l'a indiqué malheureusement
beaucoup de fausses informations
circulent sur nos concessions et leur
rentabilité en partie par manque de
pédagogie de notre part ou par manque de
pédagogie des gouvernements successifs
mais surtout surtout parce que le modèle
économique est très complexe et très
particulier
alors on retrouve même des
erreurs d'analyse dans des rapports
officiels comme celui de l'Autorité de
la concurrence en 2014 et plus récemment
comme celui du sénateur de la Haye en
2020 ou celui de l'Inspection générale
des finances en 2021 donc je vais dire
quelques mots sur ces sur ces rapports
qui ont alimenté et qui alimentent
toujours la polémique et on pourra bien
sûr y revenir dans plus en détail dans
la séquence des questions si vous le si
vous le souhaitez
en 2014
l'Autorité de la concurrence avait
analysé à tort la rentabilité
instantanée des sociétés
concessionnaires comme si nous étions
une société
industrielle ou commerciale classique
elle n'avait pas résonné sur la durée de
la concession et elle n'avait donc pas
intégré dans son analyse le coût
d'acquisition des concessions au globale
22,5 milliards d'euros pour le secteur
les dettes existantes dans les sociétés
20 milliards d'euros au global pour le
secteur et les engagements
d'investissement qui figuraient dans les
contrats 5 milliards d'euros au global
pour le secteur
l'Autorité de la concurrence avait aussi
clairement sous-estimé le fait que
l'actif sera rendu gratuitement à la fin
des concessions en bon état d'entretien
et donc totalement des endettés
fort heureusement les choses étaient
rentrées dans l'ordre à l'issue d'une
confrontation portant sur l'analyse
économique et sur les chiffres dans le
cadre d'une commission Haddock pierre
Copé moi-même avions participé à la
réunion finale qui avait permis de
rétablir la vérité et de chlore cette
première polémique fondée sur nos
comptes et sur notre rentabilité
alors deux autres rapports toujours
orientés à charge sont donc sorties
récemment sur la base de données fausses
ou peu objectives le rapport sénatorial
piloté par le sénateur de la haie
publiant cette plante 2020 et plus
récemment le rapport de
établi en février 2021 alors on peut
tout de même on peut tout de même saluer
une évolution de méthode positive dans
ces deux derniers rapports vers des
calculs plus pertinents de la
rentabilité car ils prennent en compte
cette fois le taux de rentabilité
interne le fameux tri qui analyse la
rentabilité de la concession sur
l'ensemble de sa durée
petite complication tout de même on
distingue deux types de tri le théorie
concession qui mesure la rentabilité de
la concession et donc l'équilibre
économique de contrat indépendant
indépendamment du financement et le
territ actionnaire qui mesure la
rentabilité des capitaux investis par
les actionnaires ce terrier actionnaire
il dépend bien évidemment
du financement de l'acquisition
c'est-à-dire la répartition entre la
dette et les fonds propres et il relève
donc plus des risques et périls de
l'actionnaire
alors le rapport sénatorial a étudié le
seul théorie actionnaire le rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances a
étudié à la fois le Teri actionnaire et
le territoire
mais si on se lance dans ces calculs de
théorie il faut le faire avec des
calculs juste et avec des prévisions
crédibles ceux qui n'est manifestement
pas le cas je vous le dis très
clairement
la commission d'enquête du Sénat avait
pourtant produit un travail de qualité
en 2020 et d'ailleurs nous partageons la
grande majorité des recommandations de
la commission sauf pour l'étude
financière qui comportait des erreurs
majeures de méthodologie et de
raisonnement
le sénateur de la Haye
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
avait confié cette étude complexe pour
ne pas dire très complexe au sol
monsieur Fortin qui est en réalité un
expert en fusion acquisition
d'entreprise
j'ai eu l'occasion d'alerter à plusieurs
reprises par oral ou par écrit le
sénateur malheureusement sans effet sur
les graves erreurs figurant dans son
étude financière
je vais vous donner un seul exemple qui
nous concerne
APRR pour illustrer les erreurs de cette
étude prévisionnelle
l'étude en question a été établie sur la
base de nos comptes afin 2019
hors depuis cette date trois exercices
se sont donc écoulés 2020-2021 et 2022
et on peut constater aujourd'hui que
monsieur Fortin avait très largement
surestimé dans sa prévision les
dividendes sur cette période il les a
surestimé de plus de 2 milliards d'euros
par rapport à la réalité ce qui génère
avec d'autres erreurs un écart de près
de 3% sur le territ actionnaire afin
2022 entre son étude et la réalité
quand au rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances
l'IGF n'a pas noté de problèmes
particuliers sur le tri concession
d'ailleurs ce terrible concession
constitue de notre point de vue le bon
indicateur pour mesurer la rentabilité
d'une concession contrairement au
Terrier actionnaire c'est un avis qui
est d'ailleurs partagé par la RT dans
ces deux rapports sur l'économie
générale des concessions autoroutières
de 2019 et 2023 avec une mesure des
théories concession qui est proche de
ceux attendus au moment de la
privatisation est considéré comme
raisonnable c'est-à-dire autour de 8%
au passage on peut vraiment déplorer que
cette autorité de contrôle et de
régulation indépendante ne soit pas
systématiquement placé au cœur des
débats sur la question de la rentabilité
des concessions c'est un régulateur
compétent et rigoureux qui a justement
été chargé par le législateur en 2015 de
suivre entre autres l'évolution de la
rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires
alors l'IGF a aussi étudié comme la
commission d'enquête du Sénat le terrier
actionnaire en reconnaissant certaines
erreurs du rapport sénatorial et en
rappelant le caractère hypothétique de
ses propres calculs encore une fois pour
nous comme pour la RT le terrier
actionnaire n'est pas le bon indicateur
mais si on veut le regarder ce terrier
actionnaire encore faut-il partir sur de
bonnes bases
car nous émettons en effet les plus
grandes réserves sur la fiabilité du
rapport de l'IGF qui s'inspire fortement
du modèle financier utilisé par monsieur
Fortin c'est écrit dans le rapport et je
dois dire que c'est vraiment préoccupant
en particulier pour les prévisions de
dividendes postes 2019
en réalité à date c'est-à-dire afin 2022
nous sommes les uns et les autres très
proches des objectifs qui avaient été
affichées en 2005 dans les plans
d'affaires communiqués à l'État dans le
cadre de l'appel d'offres de
privatisation on pourra revenir sur les
explications si vous le si vous le
souhaitez en tout cas c'est une
certitude et c'est facile à vérifier
alors cette situation afin 2022 elle est
extrêmement importante et elle devrait
normalement clore la polémique
récurrente sur notre soi-disante sur
rentabilité car pour le futur c'est à
dire pour les années
restantes des concessions on peut bâtir
des prévisions plus ou moins optimistes
et on le sait très bien les choses
peuvent varier très vite et de manière
très importante que ce soit dans le
domaine du trafic ou dans le domaine des
taux d'intérêts par exemple
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on ne
connaîtra la rentabilité de la
concession qu'à la fin de la concession
et que la seule vraie donnée vraiment
fiable et objective c'est la situation à
date en tout cas vous l'avez compris
nous contestons formellement toute idée
de surprofit comme on peut le lire ou
l'entendre régulièrement et ce procès
qui qui nous est fait à intervalles
réguliers est très injuste car il repose
sur des contre-vérités et sur beaucoup
d'approximations
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés alors quel avenir pour les
concessions puisque c'est le sujet qui
nous qui nous réunit qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui les concessions
autoroutières et les autoroutes c'est
avant tout un objet politique c'est qui
et notre présence ici le démontre bien
et l'avenir des concessions est
fondamentalement un choix politique un
choix politique qui doit prendre en
compte un certain nombre d'enjeux qui
s'ouvrent qui s'ouvrent devant nous des
enjeux sociétaux on va revenir dessus
des enjeux évidemment environnementaux
on va en parler et des enjeux
climatiques ce qui est sûr et ça a été
évoqué par mes par mes collègues la
concession et ça a été démontré au fil
des années et un excellent choix pour
garantir l'affectation de ressources
économiques à l'atteinte d'un objectif
un objectif sociétal si on commence par
celui-là qui est que ça a été mentionné
tout à l'heure la la réalité de la
France c'est un besoin de mobilité
individuelle et c'est une réalité
géographique vous qui êtes élu de
nombreux territoires vous le savez la
route fait a fait fait et fera pour
longtemps partie des mobilités du
quotidien de millions de millions de
Français c'est une réalité qui d'une
réalité géographique une réalité
démographique avec des territoires qui
qui croisent différemment et donc avec
des besoins différenciés entre les
différentes régions les différentes
villes les différentes collectivités qui
qui doivent assurer la mobilité et
l'accès à la mobilité à des millions de
Français parce que l'accès à la mobilité
mesdames messieurs c'est un facteur de
développement c'est un facteur de
création d'emplois c'est un facteur de
désenclavement des enjeux
environnementaux évidemment et c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement extrêmement
fort vous le savez le secteur des
transports représente un tiers des
émissions de CO2 de la France et c'est
le seul secteur qui ne diminue pas au
fil des dernières années
84% des émissions de CO2 sont sont
celles qui sont
issues de la route et en fait le secteur
autoroutier concédé que nous
représentons ici et ben représente 7%
des émissions de CO2 de la France
c'est-à-dire que le client nous les
usagers de l'autoroute représentent 7%
des émissions de CO2 pour la moitié pour
les véhicules légers pour l'autre moitié
pour les pour les poids lourds dans un
schéma où la stratégie nationale bas
carbone
définit une part modale de la route
certes en baisse mais à l'horizon 2050 à
71% quel que soit le scénario la route
est et restera le moyen de transport
prépondérant oui il faut faire du report
modal oui il faut la sobriété mais
absolument il faut des carbonner la
route des carbone et la route si on
retire répondra évidemment le report
modal le report modal c'est ce sont de
nombreux investissements réalisés
puisque on le sait à l'approche des
grandes villes
l'autosolis est une des grandes
difficultés qui engorge les accès aux
métropole avec en moyenne à l'approche
de Paris chaque matin 1,1 passager par
par véhicule et donc c'est une nécessité
urgente de développer des
infrastructures de mobilité partagée des
pôles d'échanges multimodaux des voies
express développer encore plus et nous
l'avons déjà tous fait dans nos sociétés
développer les locaux voiturage et les
parkings de covoiturage tout simplement
parce que comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure la route fait partie et fera
toujours partie de du quotidien des
Français pour se rendre pour se rendre
au travail puisque vous le savez chaque
Français n'habite pas à côté d'une gare
évidemment
évidemment c'est de la sobriété
évidemment la sobriété c'est les
pratiques les nouvelles pratiques de
travail c'est le télétravail c'est les
services de proximité c'est les circuits
courts mais c'est surtout vous le savez
la décarbonation et l'autoroute est déjà
et doit être le vecteur privilégié d'une
mobilité des carmodée c'est déjà le cas
et c'est déjà le cas depuis quelques
années puisque vous le savez le réseau
autoroutier français et très très en
avance en matière de dégâts de
possibilités décarbonation des véhicules
légers puisque nous avons massivement
installé sur l'ensemble de nos aires de
services des bandes de recharge à très
haute puissance qui permettent de
recharger très rapidement des véhicules
électriques et qui rendent la mobilité
électrique longue distance possible
aujourd'hui avec à peu près autant de
les mêmes contraintes je dirais ou les
mêmes difficultés ou la même facilité si
je positivement que avec un véhicule
avec un véhicule carboné le défi qui
s'ouvre devant nous puisque avec ces
infrastructures et nous devons continuer
à renforcer ensemble l'accès à la
mobilité électrique et l'accès à la
mobilité longue distance le l'autre
enjeu que nous avons à relever c'est la
décarbonation des poids lourds
aujourd'hui n'existe pas de technologie
mur il y a énormément de choses qui se
font mais ce qui est sûr c'est que dans
les années qui vont qui s'ouvrent devant
nous le défi de la mobilité puisque ça
représente la moitié des émissions de
CO2 du secteur c'est la décarbonation
des poids lourds qui vont nécessiter des
infrastructures lourdes des
investissements très importants ça va
nécessiter des bornes de recharge pour
les poids lourds à 1 mégawatt ça va
nécessiter d'amener sur chaque air de
services entre 20 et 50 mégawatts donc
des années d'énergie tout à fait
considérable et sans commune mesure avec
ce qui est fait sur les sur les sur les
véhicules légers l'autoroute ça doit
aussi devenir le lieu de production
d'énergie verte en fait nous avons tous
tous les trois des dizaines de milliers
d'hectares disponibles pour y construire
des des panneaux pour y installer des
panneaux solaires et pour que ces
délaissé autoroutiers pour utiliser ce
terme le terme consacré devienne de
véritables fermes solaires qui
permettent de continuer à produire et
produire plus d'énergie d'énergie verte
c'est aussi un des enjeux aussi la
fluidification la fluidification
notamment aux garde-péage par la
généralisation du flux libre le flux
libre c'est que tes technologique les
uns les autres commençons à mettre en à
mettre en place par mes non seulement
évidemment gain de temps puisque c'est
la fin de l'arrêt au garde péage mais
c'est aussi et mais c'est aussi des
économies de CO2 tout à fait
substantielle et démontré puisque
l'arrêt et le redémarrage à une guerre
de péage entraîne évidemment des
émissions de CO2 complémentaires c'est
des enjeux climatiques
et les enjeux pour les milieux naturels
climatiques avaient les enjeux
climatiques et milieux naturels tout
simplement parce que les infrastructures
que nous avons aujourd'hui qui ont été
développées depuis les années 60 ne sont
plus forcément adaptés aux enjeux
climatiques actuels sécheresse extrême
précipitations centenal qui se
produisent tous les trois ou quatre ans
et c'est là aussi pour continuer à
disposer comme on l'a dit d'une
infrastructure autoroutière qui est
probablement la meilleure d'Europe et
qui est résiliente au changement
climatique ce sont là aussi des
investissements importants pour pouvoir
transformer ces infrastructures et les
pérenniser au-delà pour les pour les
dizaines d'années qui viennent c'est
aussi on l'a dit la préservation du
milieu naturel et de la ressource en dos
et pour cela on ne peut pas attendre on
ne peut pas attendre puisque l'objectif
est fixé par l'Union européenne est une
diminution de 55% des émissions de CO2
d'ici 2030 on ne peut pas atteindre la
fin des concessions donc au mentionnait
pour les grandes concessions entre 2031
et 2036
ce serait dans ce cas là un rendez-vous
raté pour la France on ne peut pas
attendre 2031 pour décarboner le
transport le transport routier puisque
ça ferait que les objectifs que nous
sommes tous fixés que nous appelons de
nos vœux non pas été atteints alors
après ces concessions que faut-il faire
ça reste je l'ai dit évidemment un choix
politique la concession est un excellent
outil est un excellent outil qui permet
d'affecter les ressources économiques à
l'entretien et développant
d'infrastructures sans faire structure
critique du pays on parle souvent de
colonne vertébrale colonne vertébrale du
pays peut-être avec des contrats et
certainement avec des contrats de
concession un peu différents
probablement plus courts tout simplement
parce que les investissements qui sont à
faire ne sont pas de la même ampleur que
ceux qui ont été réalisés dans la
construction initiale des autoroutes
dans des périodes périmés géographiques
probablement différents plus homogène on
pourrait avec des tailles critiques qui
seraient entre 1000 et 1500 km
d'autoroute qui revient à découper le
réseau autoroutier français en 8 à 10 en
8 à 10 concessions mais toujours avec un
principe de pH puisque le pH est
fondamentalement juste puisque c'est le
principe de l'utilisateur payeur et
c'est aussi dans un pays hautement
commerçant comme la France la manière de
faire contribuer l'ensemble des
utilisateurs du réseau autoroutier
français à son entretien et à son
développement voilà avec des clauses
contractuelles avec un meilleur
équilibre entre le risque et la
rentabilité tout cela en
ayant conscience du fait que la
directive vignette s'appliquant tout ne
sera pas tout à fait possible en matière
de de péage et de fiscalité l'autoroute
est une infrastructure essentielle qui
est à surelever les défis du passé de la
sécurité routière de la mobilité de
l'urbanisation il doit être capable de
relever les défis sociétaux et
environnementaux des années qui viennent
avec le même niveau d'ambition merci de
votre attention
merci messieurs pour ce propos liminaire
nous allons venir nous allons venir aux
orateurs des groupes je salue tous les
collègues qui viennent d'autres
commissions qui s'intéressent
à nos travaux ce matin un petit rappel
les prises de parole c'est vous le savez
deux minutes par orateur deux groupes et
pour le groupe Renaissance la parole est
à Daniel brûlebois merci monsieur le
président ou nous des députés de la
majorité je tiens à vous remercier
messieurs les présidents et directeurs
pour votre présence parmi nous depuis le
début des années 1950 l'état fait le
choix du contrat de concession pour ses
19300 km d'autoroute ce qui lui permet
d'accélérer le développement du réseau
tout en faisant le choix de faire
supporter les risques liés à ce
développement addtr et d'encaisser une
importante fiscalité ce modèle n'a
jamais été remise en cause au gré des
alternances politiques par aucune
majorité les autoroutes représentent un
patrimoine public important de 150
milliards d'euros et c'est celui de tous
les Français et il faut bien le
reconnaître la France dispose d'un
maillage autoroutier qui offre à nos
concitoyens un service de qualité
confort sécurité revêtement
signalisation bornes électriques
photovoltaïques propreté comme en
témoigne la 39 autoroute verte du Jura
grâce à ses investissements importants
que les seuls moyens publics auraient eu
du mal à réaliser dans un délai
comparable nous sommes aujourd'hui les
plus performants d'Europe
à l'échéance des prochaines concessions
à partir de 2031 la gestion de ce
patrimoine sera remise en jeu or en mai
2023 de rapports ont été rendus publics
l'un de la RT l'autre de l'IGF qui
conclut à des niveaux de rentabilité qui
se situe dans la moyenne haute des
concessions merci pour votre éclairage
sur ce sujet qui méritait des précisions
sans remettre en cause le modèle
économique actuel s'il faut le repenser
d'ici la prochaine décennie notre groupe
Renaissance défend une position médiane
qui repose sur une nécessaire
renégociation des accords de concession
est plus particulièrement sur leur durée
c'est le sens de la saisine du Conseil
d'État qui porte aussi sur les questions
fiscales cela revient à dire que
l'avenir des concessions après 2031 doit
se préparer dès maintenant d'autre part
dans le projet de loi portant diverses
dispositions d'adaptation au droit de
l'Union européenne nous avons repoussé à
plus tard au moment des renégociations
l'obligation de modulation des péages
aux véhicules lourds en fonction de leur
émission de CO2 ainsi que la redevance
sur les coûts liés à la pollution
comment voyez-vous la mise en place et
la répartition de cette nouvelle
redevance qui va s'ajouter au péage
merci pour le groupe rassemblement
national la parole est à Pierre meringue
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour votre pour votre
présentation on a un petit peu
l'impression que vous êtes seul contre
tous c'est-à-dire que vous avez raison
contre contre tout le monde contre la
Cour des comptes contre l'inspection
générale des finances contre le Sénat
contre l'autorité de la concurrence nous
nous avons plutôt tendance à avoir
confiance dans nos institutions plutôt
que dans les financiers de chez KPMG et
Deloitte auquel vous faites souvent
appel il me semble que la rentabilité et
des mesurée c'est de toute façon
démontrer
récemment vous dites que il n'est pas
possible de mesurer la rentabilité avant
de la fin des contrats
ça me paraît étonnant puisque dans ce
cas là comment est-ce que vous empruntez
pour justement financer cet
investissements moi j'ai une question
qui est un petit peu passée sous les
radars ces derniers temps l'article
r3131-2 du code de la commande publique
impose à tous les conséquents
concessionnaires pardon de publier un
rapport annuel de l'état du patrimoine
autoroutier il me aujourd'hui l'État
nous dit qu'il travaille sur ce
patrimoine mais en réalité c'est à vous
de publier l'état de ce patrimoine seul
ce patrimoine nous permettrait de
calculer une vingt une valeur
d'indemnisation pour éventuellement
anticiper une résiliation anticipée des
contrats pour une remise en concurrence
dans la mesure où aujourd'hui votre
rentabilité étant démesurée le contrat
est parfaitement déséquilibré nous
n'avons pas les informations financières
là-dessus est-ce que cet état du
patrimoine vous allez le publier à
partir de maintenant annuellement et
voilà merci
merci pour le groupe la France insoumise
nups la parole est à Aymeric Caron merci
monsieur le Président Messieurs les
Présidents Monsieur le Directeur général
il y a dans votre fonction de dirigeant
de société concessionnaire d'autoroute
une contradiction qui me semble
insoluble en effet vous êtes à la tête
d'entreprise qui ont toutes pour objet
de faire du bénéfice et de faire le plus
haut bénéfice possible c'est le principe
des entreprises privées dans un modèle
économique libéral ce modèle prône par
définition la primauté de la liberté
individuelle en de nombreux domaines la
liberté d'entreprendre de consommer
d'accumuler etc mais il existe aussi
liberté revendiquée par tous la liberté
de se déplacer sans entrave consacré par
la Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme article 13 toute personne a le
droit de circuler librement à
l'intérieur d'un état or votre activité
telle que vous la pratiquez entrave
cette liberté essentielle qu'elle fait
mine de servir en exigeant des citoyens
automobilistes qui veulent se déplacer
un impôt prohibitif exemple par Irène
353 km 31 euros et 20 centimes pour
beaucoup les prix des autoroutes les
prix que vous exigé qui ont encore
augmenté de 4,75% cette année sont trop
élevés alors certes il y a le train que
nous préférons à la voiture mais c'est
un autre débat de fait les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute gagnent
beaucoup d'argent l'inspection générale
des finances parlent de 55 milliards
d'euros sur profit de sur rentabilité
12% pour Vinci et Eiffage et rien que
pour l'année 2021 les dividendes se sont
élevés à 3,3 milliards pour l'ensemble
des SR on sait que la privatisation
gérer notamment par l'actuel ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire en 2006 a été
une très mauvaise affaire pour l'État
qui n'avait pas bien évalué vos profits
à venir en réalité le réseau routier ne
peut pas être délégué au privé c'est une
question d'intérêt général en tout cas
il ne doit pas servir de Man à des
groupes privés c'est pourquoi nous
considérons que les autoroutes
françaises doivent être nationalisées et
que le prix des péages doit baisser en
attendant est-ce que vous seriez prêt
même si Bruno Le Maire ne vous le
demande pas a baissé les prix des péages
de 60% en moyenne comme le recommande
l'inspection générale des finances
merci chers collègues pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Emmanuel
Maquet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les présidents Monsieur le
Directeur Général s'il y a bien une
chose que nous avons apprise avec
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
ferroviaire c'est que la réussite d'une
concession dépend du soin avec lequel le
contrat est défini dès le départ par
l'autorité organisatrice en l'occurrence
par l'État on ne peut pas reprocher
ensuite aux concessionnaire d'exploiter
le cadre fixé à fortiori dans ce cadre
rapporte 14,8 milliards d'euros à l'État
plus une reprise de la dette de 16,8
milliards alors oui il ressort du
rapport de l'IGF que la rentabilité
supérieure à ce qui avait été
initialement prévu en 2006 le groupe
Vinci par exemple a encaissé pour 13,8
milliards d'euros de dividendes entre
2006 et 2019 alors qu'il avait déboursé
10,4 milliards d'euros pour acquérir la
concession le groupe LR rappelle que ce
n'est pas la faute des concessionnaires
si Matignon est notamment son directeur
de cabinet l'actuel ministre de
l'Économie non prévu à l'époque aucune
clause revoyure ce n'est pas non plus de
leur faute si le plan en 2015 négocier
par Emmanuel par Emmanuel Macron a
prolongé ses contrats occasionnant 4
milliards de bénéfices supplémentaires
ce n'est enfin pas la faute si les
péages augmentent puisque les prix des
péages sont fixés par décret depuis 1995
soit 11 ans avant ses concessions
j'invite par ailleurs les défenseurs de
la Renault nationalisation se souvenir
des péages publics le rythme
d'augmentation était-il différent le
prix des péages étant souvent la porte
d'entrée des Français dans ce dossier
pouvez-vous nous confirmer ce point et
notamment nous décrire en toute
transparence quels sont vos marges de
manœuvre sur ces prix de péage au
contraire de vieilles lunes de la
renationalisation le groupe les
républicains milite pour améliorer le
modèle des concessions en apprenant des
erreurs passées l'État doit gérer ses
concessions propriétaires exigeants
prudents et capables d'adapter
rapidement le deal lorsque les
conditions varient justement la
principale variation à venir c'est
l'évolution de la part modale de la
voiture et du camion pour atteindre nos
objectifs climatiques quel est votre
stratégie en la matière quelles
évolutions du trafic anticipez-vous sur
ces concessions enfin quel modèle
économique env vous pour les prochaines
années garantissant la foi le bon
entretien des infrastructures la juste
rémunération des actionnaires mais aussi
et surtout le financement de la
décarbonation du transport je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe démocrate
modem et indépendant la parole est à
Oddy merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur mes chers collègues comme vous
l'avez indiqué dans vos propres
liminaires le sujet des autoroutes
suscite bien souvent beaucoup d'intérêt
de questions plus encore à la suite de
leur privatisation alors que la fin des
concessions approche se pose la question
de leur renouvellement doit-il se faire
avec des conditions plus strictes
doit-on renationaliser c'est un vrai
débat que nous devons avoir
collectivement sur des éléments
rationnels et factuels guidés par un
triptyque l'intérêt de l'usager du
contribuable des finances publiques
aujourd'hui nous partageons le constat
fait par un très large majorité de
Français les autoroutes sont chères les
bénéfices des sociétés autoroutières
augmentent la question des montants des
dividendes versés aux actionnaires se
posent
entendons-nous bien il ne s'agit pas
pour nous de défendre la gratuité des
autoroutes mais plutôt le juste prix si
le terme gratuité est souvent invoqué
comme une solution magique par certains
il est en réalité trompeur jusqu'au bout
de la chaîne c'est bien le contribuable
qui paye les nez donc pas normal que ce
soit la logique d'usagée payeur qui
prime encore faut-il que cette
contribution soit raisonnable
aujourd'hui les enjeux du réseau routier
sont d'accompagner favoriser la
transition vers les déplacements
durables vous avez assisté sur les
enjeux environnementaux la décarbonation
des poids lourds l'accès aux mobilité la
production d'énergie verte je vous ai
également entendu sur votre engagement
pour la production d'énergie verte et
noter le rôle majeur que vous souhaitez
jouer dans la transition énergétique
mais n'y a-t-il pas des actions à mener
à court terme à cet effet je voudrais
prendre un exemple sur le rôle des
autoroutes qui agissent comme des axes
de contournement de nos communes je
prends à cet effet l'exemple de ma ville
Melun une autoroute à la scie une
autoroute à l'est la 5 de quoi pouvoir
éviter de traverser la forêt de
Fontainebleau et la ville de Melun ville
préfecture pourtant ce sont 4000 poids
lourds par jour qui transitent sans
compter les voitures avec les
conséquences que l'on connaît en terme
d'engorgement de pollution de mode
atmosphérique et sonore sur les
populations qui les subissent une vraie
question se pose sur l'emplacement de
certains pH qui induisent des
comportements d'évitement et des reports
de trafic sur des routes secondaires qui
pourraient être évitées ce pose aussi la
question de la modulation des tarifs
pour orienter les comportements je pense
notamment à la mise en place d'un tarif
local quelle réponse pourriez-vous
apporter concrètement à ces enjeux
environnementaux et d'efficacité pour
les populations merci chers collègues
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
la parole est à Bertrand petit
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les présidents et directeurs des
sociétés concessionnaires chers
collègues le sujet de l'avenir des
concessions d'autoroute ce n'est pas
seulement celui des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute le régime
concessif n'est pas une fin en soi pour
beaucoup de Français l'avenir des
concessions d'autoroute s'arrêtent là où
commence les difficultés à boucler les
fins de mois nous autoroutes c'est aux
générations qui nous précèdent que nous
les devons ce patrimoine national c'est
le nôtre pourtant emprunter nos
autoroutes nous coûtent de plus en plus
cher plus 4,75% depuis février c'est un
problème pour se rendre au travail c'est
aussi un problème à l'approche des
vacances à quelques jours de l'été quel
geste messieurs êtes-vous prêt à faire
il se dit que cette hausse du prix du
péage est justifiée par l'inflation
subie par les sociétés concessionnaires
pour assumer les investissements
auxquels elles se sont engagées mais
avec des profits exorbitants réalisés
l'année dernière
2,2 milliards pour Vinci un milliard
pour ap2r et plus de 70% de marge brute
ce qui signifie que les frais d'ex qui
sont seules touchés par l'inflation ne
représente que 30% de votre chiffre
d'affaires la note vous en conviendrez
et pour le moins salé pour les Français
comprenez-vous les automobilistes qui
ont le sentiment d'être pris en otage
par vos actionnaires avec la hausse
qu'il subisse j'insiste sur le contraste
saisissant entre les difficultés
subissent chaque jour par les usagers de
nos autoroutes et les profits
exorbitants de vos actionnaires le prix
du pH payé par les uns c'est les profits
ont pochés par les autres le rapport de
l'inspection l'inspection générale des
finances dont j'ai bien entendu qu'il
n'avait pas grâce à vos yeux que le
ministre des Finances a d'ailleurs tenu
secret pendant près de deux ans révèle
n'en déplaisent le déséquilibre
manifeste des concessions comment
justifier vous cette hausse devant la
représentation nationale c'est-à-dire
devant les Français pour y remédier
l'IGF propose de baisser le prix du
péage de près de
60%. prenez vous l'engagement
conformément aux recommandations de
réduire le prix des péages je vous
remercie de votre attention merci
pour le groupe horizon et apparenté la
parole est à 20 centièmes
merci monsieur le Président
Messieurs mes chers collègues le modèle
est concession autoroutier comme nous
l'avons actuellement nous lui
reconnaître quand même un avantage si ça
permet de développer les infrastructures
et comme vous l'avez évoqué d'avoir le
système l'un des meilleurs systèmes
autoroutiers européens avec ce modèle
pour avec assez peu d'investissement il
faut l'avouer aussi de la part de
finances publiques et cela contribue
aussi par rapport aux bénéfices réalisés
au budget d'État toutefois aujourd'hui
avec les enjeux que nous avons dans la
transition écologique je rappelle que
30% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sont émis par la route aujourd'hui
nous avons un plan d'investissement pour
de la décarbonation du système routier
de 60 à 70 milliards pour répondre à ces
enjeux qui sont pas des enjeux
politiques mais bien des songes de
générationnel et de d'avenir pour nos
enfants et leurs enfants Les enfants de
nos enfants il nous faut aller plus loin
et je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
aujourd'hui de ce qui a été dit
auparavant puisque vous êtes largement
sol ce sujet des bénéfices que vous avez
réalisé sur le palette application mais
on voit aussi que nos modèles actuels
est à croiser d'injonction
contradictoires en même temps nous
voulons contraindre l'utilisation de la
voiture et en même temps nous vous
demandons de baisser les tarifs pour
mieux utiliser la voiture ce qui est
assez contradictoire mais ce qui montre
bien aussi toute la problématique
aujourd'hui de réalisation de la
transition la question qui m'intéresse
plus c'est effectivement comment prévoir
l'avenir comment prévoir l'avenir de ses
nouveaux modèles de concession de
nouveaux modèles de contrats qui vont
pouvoir permettre de financer la
décarbonation peuvent être permettre de
développer des infrastructures
nécessaires que ce soit modalités en
termes de de recharge de voiture
électrique en termes de aussi de
covoiturage il nous faut aussi aller
plus loin et je pense aussi comment y
associer les collectivités territoriales
sur lesquelles les autoroutes sont des
éléments structurants essentiels par
rapport à ça donc ma question tout
simplement c'est comment voyez-vous ces
nouveaux contrats notamment avec
aujourd'hui à proposition de Clément
bonne qui souhaite y associer les ONG
les parlementaires mais l'ensemble des
acteurs pour réfléchir ces nouveaux nous
vous contrats et aussi la demande
notamment faite par la RT dire que faut
peut-être prévoir des durées moins
longues effectivement pour que l'État
soit puissant en rapport de force par
rapport à vous merci pour le groupe
écologiste la parole est accessible Argi
oui merci monsieur le Président
messieurs le maillage autoroutier c'est
le modèle qui a choisi la France pour
ses mobilités elle a choisi ce modèle et
les écologistes s'ils sont toujours
opposés car il s'est toujours fait au
détriment du ferroviaire fleuron de
notre pays dans les années 60 et
abandonné par tous les gouvernements
successifs les écologistes n'ont cessé
de se battre et continuent encore
aujourd'hui à se battre contre ce type
d'infrastructures qui favorise
l'hypermétropolisation et empêche toute
réorientation vers des mobilités
décarbonées en particulier en matière de
fret et ligne de desserte fine il s'agit
là en effet d'un choix politique qui ne
relève pas de votre responsabilité vous
l'avez dit Monsieur Copé je crois mais
qui mérite d'être rappelé à l'heure où
des projets autoroutiers compte encore
en cours et doivent être abandonnés y
compris le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures en parlent sans le
prendre de position bien entendu du coup
je vais me contenter de vous poser des
questions sur le modèle des concessions
monsieur Copé en premier dans votre
interview au Parisien le 14 mars vous
avez indiqué avant d'avoir lu le rapport
de l'ignf j'imagine qu'il faut arrêter
de raconter n'importe quoi sur les
concessions d'autoroute alors maintenant
que vous l'avez lu ce rapport
considérez-vous toujours que nous
racontons ou que l'IGF raconte n'importe
quoi sur ses concessions autoroutières
lors de son audition en commission des
finances le 22 mars dernier en ma
présence Bruno Le Maire a répété que les
concessions étaient caractérisées par
une surentabilité reconnaissant que les
calculs de l'état relatif au taux de
rembours rentabilité interne actionnaire
et à la dette levée par les sociétés
autoroutières se sont révélées erronées
l'État a donc sous-évalué l'avantage
financier revenant à vos sociétés alors
que pensez-vous de la proposition numéro
31 de la commission d'enquête sur le
contrôle la régulation l'évolution des
concessions autoroutières du Sénat de
2020 qui propose explicitement notamment
de réviser les clauses d'encadrement de
la rentabilité des contrats de
concession historiques afin de les
rendre potentiellement opérante
merci
chers collègues pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine la parole est
à Hubert vue de France Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Je vous ai écouté
attentivement en quelque sorte vous
n'accordez à la puissance publique à
l'état qu'une seule clairvoyance celle
de 2005 de vous avoir effectivement
confié les les autoroutes bien après
selon vos propos et bien l'état et c'est
une succession d'erreurs une succession
d'erreurs une succession de graves
inexactitude sur l'appréciation portée
par la puissance publique sur le
développement de ces concessions
erreur sans doute également
l'appréciation du ministre récente qui
admet et bien une faille majeure dans la
décision de l'état de 2005 par ailleurs
que vous vous disqualifier d'un trade
plume le tri actionnaire qui pour vous
n'est pas un indicateur valable bref
circuler il y a rien à voir
on comprendrait mieux à votre écoute et
bien le paciter des rapports entre
l'État et les sociétés autoroutes que
vous représentez à l'eau ni compris du
dernier contentieux soulevé par la RT
sur votre demande de majoration des
péages et
elle appréciation sur les 800 millions
qui n'étaient absolument pas justifiés
bref on a l'impression d'avoir une
situation et c'est surréaliste dans ce
débat et à cette heure pour notre part
le groupe communiste vous le savez
défend le choix et bien d'une régie
d'une retour en régie public qui
permette effectivement de diriger le
les péages et bien vers la transition
écologique et les transports alternatifs
pour lesquels nous plaidons également
pour des outils publics merci
merci enfin pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires la
parole est à Guy Bricout
Messieurs mes chers collègues alors je
souhaitais pour commencer revenir sur le
dossier de l'échangeur à deux Avensis
dans ma circonscription qui va finir par
voir le jour et je fais d'ailleurs à
vous remercier néanmoins ce projet
malgré son caractère indispensable pour
le territoire malgré le fait que ce type
de travaux soit en grande partie à votre
charge et
apparu particulièrement difficile à
faire aboutir il est ainsi fallu qu'il
passe par le Conseil d'État et aussi par
les RT alors je trouve ces procédures
par trop complexes pour se des dossiers
qui relèvent avant tout des territoires
et je vous demande ce que vous en pensez
alors à part avoir dit du bien je vais
dire du mal j'ai eu beaucoup de déboires
avec la SNCF et j'en ai déjà parlé lors
d'une visite précédente de votre visite
précédente donc arrivé à Roissy à
l'autoroute est fermée on vous envoie
dans la nature et dans la nature il y a
plus de fléchage et mon GPS s'affolem
aura venait toujours sur l'autoroute et
l'autoroute était fermée donc j'ai passé
une heure un quart avant d'arriver à
destination n'est-il pas possible que
vous preniez en charge le l'usager
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à destination
alors que vous réservez déjà certaines
restos en nos automobilistes réguliers
beaucoup de nos concitoyens notamment
dans les hauts de France réclament une
gratuité ou tout ou moins une réduction
quand ils empruntent les autoroutes
situées dans leur secteur de résidence
comment envisageriez-vous cette idée et
le cas échéance ou quelles conditions
seriez-vous prêt à travailler comment
défendez-vous le fait que nos autoroutes
soient les plus chères d'Europe nous
concitoyens notamment en ces temps de
crise ont de plus en plus de mal à le
comprendre et à l'accepter et enfin
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles sont
vos prochains investissements pour
adopter nos routes aux besoins
environnementaux et notamment en matière
de développement de l'électrique et de
l'hydrogène quels sont vos perspectives
en la matière
et pouvez-vous nous préciser que
l'impact exact a eu sur vos sociétés la
réduction de l'impôt sur les sociétés je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues merci d'avoir tenu
notamment les deux minutes je vous
laisse la parole en sachant qu'on a déjà
une petite vingtaine de questions d'une
minute merci merci monsieur le Président
moi je voudrais
rappeler deux trois choses d'abord nous
sommes concessionnaires de l'État
et nous sommes fiers de ce que nous
faisons nous exécutons nos contrats et
je voudrais ici dire que nous
représentons à nous trois douze mille
salariés qui assurent un service de
qualité 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
et je pense que c'est important de le
rappeler et c'est important de rappeler
que jamais
dans toutes les polémiques dont nous
sommes entourés n'a été mis en question
notre capacité à exécuter nos
obligations contractuelles et notre
capacité à respecter nos contrats moi je
comprends parfaitement qu'il y ait dans
l'état et dans la représentation
nationale des débats sur la question de
savoir si vaut mieux faire les
autoroutes en régie ou pas en régie je
comprends même la question concernant
l'opportunité du péage mais c'est pas
notre débat nous nous sommes
concessionnaires l'état organise des
appels d'offres pour construire des
infrastructures ou privatises des
concessions nous y répondons nous y
répondons
dans un cadre qui est archi contrôlé
contrôlé par l'Autorité de régulation
des transports contre les par la
Commission européenne contre les par le
Conseil d'État contrôlé par le Parlement
et nous appliquons des politiques
publiques qui à aucun moment ne relève
de nous nous appliquons dans le cadre de
nos contrats des décisions de l'État
donc s'il vous plaît ne nous demandez
pas d'être comptable de décision de
l'État ensuite vous nous posez des
questions sur la manière dont nous
exécutons nos contrats et on est là pour
ça et on est là pour pour en parler
d'abord la question est revenue
plusieurs fois
de façon polémique vous vous nous dites
vous êtes seul contre tous et vous
contestez les mises en cause des
contrats et bah oui nous contestons ce
qui a été les conclusions du rapport de
l'Autorité de la concurrence de 2014 qui
a envoyé tout le monde dans le mur en
prenant un modèle qui n'avait pas
compris que une concession était un
modèle d'investissement et en comparant
les résultats des sociétés
concessionnaires à des sociétés
d'exploitation pardon mais lorsque nous
portons des dizaines de milliards
d'euros d'engagement d'investissement
des dizaines de milliards d'euros de
dettes nous demandons à ce que nos
modèles soient regardés dans leur
complexité et pas simplement en
regardant l'excédent brut d'exploitation
qui est évidemment très nombreux pardon
mais nous demandons aussi que quand on
regarde les chiffres qu'on nous jette à
la figure régulièrement il soit mis en
regard des montants que nous
investissons vous les connaissez ils ont
été dit ici je les reprends pas mais
il faut savoir de quoi on parle et
savoir à quoi on compare les chiffres et
donc pardon de dire ça mais je crois que
c'est important
lorsque on veut juger le travail des
sociétés concessionnelles d'avoir en
tête d'une part quel est leur mission de
ne pas leur demander d'assumer des
décisions de l'État et de s'assurer que
les contrats sont appliqués et respectés
et oui les contrats sont appliqués et
respectés dans la question qui a été
posée tout à l'heure sur la valeur du de
des concessions et du patrimoine réalisé
tous les ans nous rendons à l'état des
rapports sur le les constructions les
investissements et l'état du patrimoine
est suivi de façon tout à fait précise
par les services de la Direction
générale des infrastructures de
transport et de la mer qui doivent
pouvoir répondre à la question dans les
contes de l'État pour répondre de
manière plus chiffrée monsieur dans les
comptes de l'État la valorisation des
concessions d'autoroute et sauf erreur
prise pour 200 milliards d'euros
c'est en tout cas la réponse que je peux
vous donner à brûle pourpoint compte
tenu de la question que vous posez et je
voudrais enfin
dire que
je suis toujours
étonné
des griefs qui sont faits ou des débats
dans lesquels nous passons beaucoup de
temps alors même que nous sommes face à
des enjeux de décarbonation et des
besoins d'investissement sur lequel nous
avons beaucoup travaillé et sur lequel
lesquels nous avons fait beaucoup de
propositions et pour lesquelles il nous
semble qu'un travail constructif
pourrait être réalisé par l'ensemble des
acteurs voilà ce que je voulais répondre
en
à l'ensemble enfin de manière globale
aux questions qui viennent d'être listés
peut-être Philippe tu tu veux
oui on a on a eu effectivement beaucoup
de beaucoup de questions sur le sur le
sujet polémique de notre rentabilité
j'ai essayé dans la dans la dans
l'exposé liminaire de vous expliquer
quelle était la quelle était la
situation je veux vraiment insister sur
cette sur le fait que afin 2022 nous
sommes les uns et les autres très
proches du plan d'affaires qui était
communiqué à l'État au moment de la
privatisation après pour les années
restantes on peut effectivement faire
des hypothèses des prévisions plus ou
moins optimistes plus ou moins
pessimistes mais sur la base des
prévisions
réaliste que nous communiquons chaque
année
à l'État au ministère des Transports et
à la haute irrégulation des transports
la RT nous sommes en fin de concession
sur un théorie proche de celui qui était
indiqué au moment de la privatisation
alors pourquoi nous trouvons-nous à peu
près dans les eaux du business plan
d'affaires initial c'est extrêmement
simple sur le côté chiffre d'affaires
nous sommes très décalés par rapport aux
objectifs qu'avaient indiqué nos
actionnaires au moment de la
privatisation nous avons connu une crise
économique et financière extrêmement
graves en 2008-2009 le trafic poids
lourd par exemple ABC de près de 20% sur
deux ans en 2008-2009 ce qui n'était
absolument pas les hypothèses qui
avaient été faites pour valoriser les
concessions nous avons subi la crise des
gilets jaunes qui n'a pas été neutre sur
le trafic 2018 et 2019 et nous avons
surtout subi une crise sanitaire
exceptionnelle en 2020 et 2021 ce qui
fait que au niveau du trafic et donc
chiffre d'affaires nous sommes en
décalage très important par rapport au
plan d'affaires initial ça c'est pour
les moins alors il y a effectivement
quand on regarde les choses le meilleur
objectif des plus notamment au niveau
des taux d'intérêt pour financer nos
dettes qui sont considérables nous avons
pu bénéficier non pas depuis l'origine
depuis 2006 mais depuis 2010 sur une sur
une petite dizaine d'années de taux
d'intérêt relativement bas qui nous ont
permis de refinancer notre dette qui est
encore une fois est considérable alors
je vous parle aujourd'hui encore sur APL
nous avons 8 milliards d'euros de dettes
à rembourser d'ici la fin de la
concession nous avons bénéficié de taux
d'intérêt plutôt bas c'est un c'est un
c'est un plus évident malheureusement
les taux d'intérêt sont en train de
remonter très fortement depuis un an un
an et on ne sait pas comment les choses
vont évoluer mais toujours est-il que
quand on regarde le l'évolution du
résultat net sur la durée nous sommes
parfaitement dans les clous et ça c'est
très facile à démontrer et je pense que
ces deux natures à considérer que nous
ne sommes pas en sur profit
concernant le rapport de l'IGF bon
je ne suis pas rentré dans le détail
tout à l'heure mais
nous n'avons pas le plan d'affaires de
l'gf nous avons le plan d'affaires de
l'étude sanatorielle mais nous n'avons
pas le plan d'affaire de l'gf simplement
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
le tri de référence pris par
l'IGF n'est pas le bon le territoire P
par les GF en tes réactionnaire c'est
cette virgule 67% pour pour l'hygs ce
serait le même tri de référence pour les
trois groupes autoroutiers ça n'a
absolument pas de sens le tri
concessionnaire dépend de manière très
importante de la structure de
financement de l'acquisition la
répartition entre dette et fonds propres
plus les actionnaires prennent de la
dette plus le tri est important donc on
ne peut pas avoir le même théorie de
7,67 et nous lorsqu'on regarde le
business plan qui a été fourni à l'État
au moment de la privatisation en 2005 le
tri sur lequel que l'on retrouve à
partir du business plan c'est 9,4%. donc
déjà sur la référence
on n'est pas dans les clous sur le sur
le sur l'IGF quand vous dites qu'on est
seul contre tous non ce n'est pas vrai
je répète qu'il y a une autorité de
régulation et de contrôle qui a été
écrit en 2015 avec une centaine
d'experts extrêmement compétents et
indépendant et qui ne partagent pas
l'analyse du rapport sénatorial et du
rapport de du rapport de l'ignf donc je
pense que il serait intéressant de
remettre au centre du jeu cette autorité
indépendante et en ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes prêts à la plus grande
transparence nous sommes prêts à mettre
sur la table les chiffres et à démontrer
que la situation n'est pas celle qui est
décrite dans certains rapports
en contrepoint de ce que vient de dire
Philippe et en écho à la question qui a
été posée sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme je savais que la question allait
te poser j'ai regardé
ce qui j'ai recalculé l'impôt sur les
sociétés payées par ASF depuis la
privatisation nous avons payé 8
milliards d'impôts sur les sociétés
c'est à 0,2 % prêt ce qui était prévu
dans le plan d'affaires incroyable
enfin pour revenir sur la question de de
Monsieur Guy Bricout
sur sur le temps que Camille Camille la
construction d'un échangeur
particulièrement nécessaire dans le
cadre du canal du canal c'est Nord et on
s'était vu à plusieurs reprises à ce
titre et tout ça c'est finalement la
démonstration d'une chose la
démonstration de comme on dit mes
collègues nous sommes extrêmement
contrôlés d'abord l'autoroute
contrairement à ce qui se dit
l'autoroute est un bien public l'État
n'a jamais vendu les autoroutes les
autoroutes restent un bien public et
resteront et le restaurant toujours et
donc nous n'avons pas loisir la
possibilité de de construire un
échangeur de modifier cette
infrastructure sans sans un nombre de
contrôle considérable d'abord le
contrôle de notre de notre conséquent
donc la DGTM avec des expertises
pointues et des contrôles extrêmement
précis ensuite le contrôle la RT on a
été mentionné à plusieurs reprises et
chacun de nos plans d'investissement
sont sont contrôlés avec un niveau de
détail très important par la RT qui
justifie que les montants
d'investissement sont effectivement les
bons et ensuite le contrôle du Conseil
d'État sur la légalité de nos avenants
et donc tout ça ça fait effectivement
qu'un investissement absolument
nécessaire prend beaucoup de temps
contrôle et transparence et une question
tout à l'heure sur l'état l'état de
l'infrastructure l'état de
l'infrastructure autoroutière et
communiquer de façon extrêmement
transparente tous les ans ça a été dit
par Pierre Copé tout à l'heure mais je
le redis par le par le notre considant
il y a nous émettons tous les ans comme
c'est prévu par la loi et comme c'est
prévu par nos contrats un compte rendu
annuel d'exploitation qui précise dans
un grand niveau de détails l'état de
l'infrastructure l'état des chaussées
l'état des ouvrages d'art signalons au
passage que les ouvrages d'art du réseau
autoroutier sont bien bien bien meilleur
état que les ouvrages pas de Retiers des
droits des autres réseaux routiers et
c'est suivi avec des indicateurs
techniques très précis qui donnent lieu
s'ils ne sont pas atteints à des
pénalités contractuelles et je pense
qu'aucun des groupes autoroutiers ici
présents ne payent des pénalités sur
l'état de l'infrastructure donc nous
sommes extrêmement contrôlés et avec des
services de l'État qui ont des moyens
d'investigation très fort et des moyens
d'audit extrêmement extrêmement forts
c'est vrai ça entraîne du temps ça
entraîne du temps pour les collectivités
qui ont besoin d'un investissement parce
que les choses notamment pas la liberté
de faire exactement ce que ce que nous
ce que nous voulons et que nous sommes
sous un sous un contrat qui peut être
extrêmement dur en termes de en termes
de contrôle et en termes de pénalité si
l'exécution de nos de nos de nos
obligations ne sont pas réalisées
notamment vous parlez monsieur Bricout
de la signalisation sur la signalisation
alors je connais pas le cas précis de
votre mésaventures mais sur la sur la
signalisation nous avons notamment des
des indicateurs là aussi pénalisables
qui précise le les délais qui sont
extrêmement courts entre la survenance
d'un événement et le moment où ces
communiqués à nos anneaux à nos
usagers du réseau routier voilà donc
contrairement à ce qui se dit nous
sommes extrêmement contrôlés nous
travaillons en toute transparence en
toute transparence aussi dans
l'attribution nos marchés puisque vous
savez que nous sommes assujettis au code
au code de la commande publique et avec
la RT qui produit annellement je vous en
recommande la lecture de nombreux
rapports et notamment des rapports sur
la bonne attribution des marchés passés
par l'ensemble des sociétés
concessionnaires voilà ce que je voulais
ajouter par en plus de ce qu'on dit mes
collègues
je vous remercie pour les réponses
apportées nous en venant donc aux
questions chers collègues a beaucoup
beaucoup de questions dans ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on fasse de l'eau
de questions d'une dizaine de questions
ne vous inquiétez pas si vous n'êtes pas
dans le premier lot je ne vais pas
oublier question donc d'une minute David
Valence
bien je vais poser une question étrange
et volontairement étrange d'abord parce
que je vais parler d'avenir et on a
beaucoup parlé du présent des
concessions je vais vous parler de votre
avenir dans cette question et je vais
pas parler du mode de gestion mais
plutôt des revenus qui sont tirés
aujourd'hui des autoroutes
comment vous évaluez un travail qui va
forcément commencer du côté de l'État
mais comment vous évaluez la capacité
après 2031 à maintenir au moins le
niveau des recettes de péage actuel et
le niveau des recettes fiscales car
d'après la directive europignac si on
l'interprète de façon stricte qui est
malheureusement encore souvent le cas il
y a un vrai risque sur la capacité à
maintenir ses recettes de péage après
2031 et donc à suscité si elles étaient
amenées à baisser une forme de report
modal inversé en particulier pour le
trafic de marchandises je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Huguette tiegna
ma question concerne aussi l'avenir mais
en termes d'innovation vous avez évoqué
que sur
dans vos dans votre stratégie vous avez
acté les déploiement du soleil pour
verdir un peu
tout ce qui est autoroute dans ma
question elle va plus loin bien sûr sur
le sujet de la mobilité il y a aussi la
question des bonnes électriques qui
incombent bien sûr à l'état et aux
collectivités mais je souhaitais savoir
quelle est la stratégie notamment de
Vinci Autoroutes pour permettre en fait
au moins de rural de pouvoir aussi se
charger dans les airs d'autoroute et
pourquoi pas demain peut-être pouvoir
charger avec de l'hydrogène produite via
l'utilisation des panneaux solaires dans
les dans les aides dans les airs
d'autoroute je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapport de la RTS steam que le secteur
autoroutier concédé devra faire face à
d'importants besoins d'investissement
d'atténuation et d'adaptation au
changement climatique il note notamment
l'inadéquation du parc de bonnes de
bornes de recharge pour les voitures
électriques avec l'ambition de
décarbonation des véhicules des carboner
la route est un enjeu est un enjeu
majeur pour le réseau comment
entendez-vous valoriser les délaissés et
à bord routier par exemple en les
mettant au service de la production
d'énergie renouvelable par ailleurs quel
bilan tirez-vous de la construction des
ecos pont permettant de favoriser le
déplacement de la faune tournant tout en
assurant la sécurité des automobilistes
plus largement quelles actions sautées
vous mener pour et amplifier pour
favoriser la biodiversité et participer
à la transition écologique
merci la parole est à Damien Adam
merci monsieur le Président et messieurs
pour votre présence ce matin il est vrai
que les autoroutes concédées montrent
une qualité de service importante plus
que dans les autres pays et sur et plus
que dans les routes nationales et
départementales la contrepartie de cette
qualité importante ce sont des prix des
péages parmi les plus élevés d'Europe et
jugés excessifs par de nombreux citoyens
et vous n'envez pas parlé ce matin je
reviens au rapport de l'IGF puisqu'il
envisage une fin anticipée des
concessions contenu du tri précité au 30
avril 2026 pour ASF et Escota et au 30
septembre 2026 pour apr et area lors de
l'audition des ministres le 22 mars
dernier dans notre commission conjointe
avec la commission des finances l'État a
annoncé la saisine du Conseil la saisine
du Conseil d'État pourrait étudier cette
possibilité savez-vous quand les
conclusions de cette saisine seront
rendues que pensez-vous des conclusions
de notamment sur cette fin anticipée des
concessions tout comme que pensez-vous
des annonces des ministres du ministre
Clément bonne ce matin sur la mise en
place d'un geste sur les péages pour les
s en vacances cet été je vous remercie
merci d'avoir été Jean-François lovizolo
la parole est à Nicolas dragon
Nicolas dragon
merci monsieur le Président zulezi mes
chers collègues messieurs les
représentants des autoroutes de France
j'ai juste une simple question compte
tenu de vos bénéfices à hurissant pour
rappel le bénéfice net 2021 des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute a augmenté
de près de 47 % en 2021 pour atteindre
3,9 milliards d'euros
dépassant celui de 2019 d'environ 11%.
constater par l'Autorité de régulation
des transports alors compte tenu de la
forte inflation qui touche l'ensemble de
nos compatriotes sur les carburants
l'alimentaire pour ne citer que ces
exemples quand allez-vous faire un geste
visant à faire baisser les tarifs de nos
autoroutes afin de rendre leur argent au
français je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Loïc Prudhomme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapports se suivent et empilent les
éléments chiffrés qui démontent que vous
vous en mettez plein les poches en
vidant les nôtres en nouvelle-aquitaine
nous avons aussi quelques exemples pour
nous rendre compte concrètement avec
l'autoroute A65 longtemps considéré
comme la plus chère de France et vous
l'auriez aujourd'hui sur la 63 la 65
construite entre Langon et Pau sur des
prévisions de trafic truqué et peu
rentables du fait de sa faible
fréquentation mais peu importe le
partenariat qui voulait à l'État aux
collectivité territoriales prévoit un
dédommagement si une certaine
rentabilité n'est pas atteinte je résume
pile les usagers paix vos péages
prohibitifs face les contribuables vous
des dommages et au final ce sont les
actionnaires qui s'en mettent plein les
poches alors ma question est assez
simple quand allez-vous arrêter de
prendre les contribuables français pour
des vaches à lait et assumer vos fiasco
sur vos deniers je vous remercie la
parole est à Sylvain carrière
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
représentants des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute magouille
et a bien de bien public c'est comme ça
qu'on pourrait résumer la gestion des
concessions
ôté retières ces 20 dernières années
malgré vous dire l'inspection générale
des finances rapporte que deux tiers des
portions autoroutières font des supers
profits à hauteur de 60%. Bruno Le Maire
est donc au courant et pourtant il vous
autorise à distribuer 3,3 milliards de
dividendes annuels sans dénoter de
Macron qui vous a offert le plan de
relance autoroutier en 2015
mais l'argent ne fait pas tout Vinci la
bien vu avait le contournement ouest de
Montpellier vous qui espérez financer
les travaux en augmentant les tarifs sur
les portions voisines c'était sans
compter sur le retour cash du Conseil
d'État mais quand vous n'aurez plus des
Macron dès le maire et qu'on sort que
pensez-vous qu'il adviendra de votre
activité les autoroutes seront de
nouveau national et les 55 milliards de
dividendes accumulées en 30 ans vous
seront repris cela représente 63%
d'excédents brut jusqu'à la fin de
l'exploitation que nous récupérerons
comme le Conseil l'inspection générale
des finances je vous remercie enfin la
parole est à François Ruffin
merci monsieur le Président les rapports
s'enchaînent de leur été autorité la
concurrence de l'Inspection générale des
finances du Sénat de la raffaire de
l'UFC Que Choisir et vous nous dites
aujourd'hui que vous êtes des martyrs
parce que ils ont tous tort mais vous
avez raison tout seul néanmoins cette
année les bénéfices des sociétés
d'autoroute c'est 4,5 milliards d'euros
les dividendes ça va être aux alentours
de 4 milliards d'euros c'est à dire que
plus de 80% de vos bénéfices ne vont pas
en investissement pour l'avenir mais
vient à rétribuer les actionnaires à la
place du déni à la place des profits je
dirais soyez gentil soyez gentil pour
les Français cet été vous dites que
c'est un objet politique les ePages mais
c'est avant tout un objet du quotidien
pour les français fait que FH ça n'avait
Vinci soit pas les sociétés les plus
haies perçues aujourd'hui comme étant
des parasites offrez aux Français pour
qui les vacances vont être bien
compliquées pour qui les transports sont
le premier poste de dépenses pendant les
vacances offrez-leur le pH gratuit et
vous verrez que avec ça si vous faites
preuve de la compréhension des
difficultés des Français vous dites si
vous démontrez votre appartenance à la
nation si en plus à la rentrée vous
baissez le tarif des péages et bien vous
ne serez plus perçu comme étant
seulement des parasites
merci Pierre Vatin voulait prendre pour
finir sur ce premier lot de questions
merci monsieur le Président Messieurs
les Présidents oui je voulais revenir
comme le collègue Valence je voulais
revenir comme le collègue Valence sur le
revignette et l'article 1224 du code de
la voirie routière et savoir comment
vous pourrez aborder l'évolution des
péages du prix des péages après la fin
des concessions et puis de la même façon
comment le mode de financement du des
100 milliards pour la SNCF pour le
chemin pour le ferroviaire pourra être
abondé par les sociétés d'autoroute
davantage que ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
et de la même façon comment l'appel du
ministre des Transports ce matin à un
geste commercial de 10% est-il ressenti
je vous remercie
je vous laisse le soin de répondre et
puis on adore c'est déjà une petite
dizaine de questions juste après je vais
faire mes meilleures efforts et je vais
commencer monsieur Ruffin bien que vous
nous ayez traité de parasites qui me
paraît pas relever de la courtoisie
élémentaire
par citer le chancelier Schmitt vous
vous souvenez que Helmut disait que les
profits d'aujourd'hui sont les
investissements de demain ça c'est les
règles de l'économie capitaliste dans
les concessions c'est exactement
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que les profits
d'aujourd'hui financent les
investissements d'hier et donc je crois
que vous me donnez l'occasion
d'expliquer que les profits que nous
font faisons aujourd'hui rembourse les
investissements que nous avons fait hier
alors ensuite je voudrais répondre à la
question de David Valence
sur la question de l'avenir du du pH
d'abord pour dire que
le pH il existe depuis la loi de 1955 et
que il n'est possible que dans le cadre
des contrats de concession quand on sort
des contrats de concession il n'y a plus
de base contractuelle au péage il n'y a
plus de base légale au pH je crois que
c'est important de le dire et je pense
que c'est important que
dans la conception des politiques
publiques cette question soit bien
comprise à la fin des contrats de
concession il n'y a plus de contrat et
quand il n'y a plus de contrat il n'y a
plus de base légale au péage en fait pas
de plus de basse contractuelle au péage
et je crois que c'est important de
l'avoir en tête après s'il doit y avoir
d'autres bases il faut de nouveau
contrats et on rentre dans le
de la
directive Eurovignette et
j'ai moi aussi des lectures
parlementaires et j'ai lu le rapport de
du coi et le rapport du coi dit que les
recettes de pH donc je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure qu'elle représentait 12,4
milliards en 2022
les recettes de péage dans le cadre de
la directive Eurovignette et dans un
scénario où il n'y aurait plus les
contrats de dans un scénario de fin des
contrats de concession c'est-à-dire
entre maintenant et 2036 les recettes de
péage seraient de du tiers de ce
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui ce qui veut
dire d'une part que l'État y perdrait
l'assiette fiscale des 4,7 milliards
d'euros qui sont prélevés sur le péage
et d'autre part qu'il perdrait le les
recettes
sanctuarisées par le pH dans les
contrats de concession et je pense que
c'est un débat qui est extrêmement
important qui est techniquement très
compliqué compte tenu des deux
directives européennes qui s'appliquent
et
compte tenu de la sensibilité du sujet
je ne peux que vous renvoyer monsieur
Valence à la lecture du rapport du coi
vous nous avez moi aussi j'ai le droit
d'avoir un peu d'humour
vous nous avez interrogé sur
notre capacité à faire un geste
commercial sur les péages
à l'occasion de l'été je voudrais
d'abord dire
que l'ensemble des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute offre à
leurs usagers des systèmes d'abonnement
et des systèmes de réduction qui
atteignent parfois plus de 60% du
montant des pH sur des trajets qui sont
indiqués je voudrais rappeler que nous
avons consenti à la demande du ministre
des Transports au début de l'année un
abondement des réductions à 40%
Ulysse 40 chez VINCI Autoroutes sur des
trajets domicile travail réguliers et
que nous avons donc conscience de la
nécessité de faire des efforts
commerciaux ensuite sur la question de
l'été elle a été posée ce matin par le
Ministre des Transports et nous
réserverons donc
à notre précédent la réponse à la
sollicitation qui a été faite sur ce
sujet je rappelle que que les pH sont
les contreparties des investissements
que nous consentons qu'ils font l'objet
d'arrêter ministériel qui sont
l'application des contrats qui sont
eux-mêmes des décrets en Conseil d'État
et que nous n'avons aucune prise sur la
fixation DPPH qui sont négociés dans le
cadre de l'équilibre général des
contrats tel qu'il est négocié au moment
de la conclusion de des concessions
Philippe doit maintenant vous répondre
sur les délaissés
quelques précisions sur la décarbonation
des autoroutes un certain nombre de
questions ont été posées sur le sur le
sujet pour dire que nous avons engagé
très concrètement sur nos réseaux la
transition écologique depuis plusieurs
années au travers de réalisation sur sur
plusieurs axes d'abord le développement
des mobilités partagées nous avons plus
de 10000 places de parking de
covoiturage qui sont offerts à notre
clientèle sur nos différents réseaux et
c'est parkings sont en progression
permanente nous avons d'ores et déjà
ouverte d'ouvert une voie réservée aux
covoiturage sur à 48 à Grenoble
nous allons construire des pôles
d'échanges multimodo en entrée de
grandes villes
et surtout nous avons équipé massivement
l'ensemble de nos aires de service de
station de bornes de recharge électrique
haute puissance et très haute puissance
sur le solaire les la question a été a
été posée bon la nouvelle loi AER que le
président évoquait en introduction va
nous permettre d'équiper massivement nos
parkings d'ombrière photovoltaïques mais
dans ce domaine nous avons déjà engagé
le mouvement depuis plusieurs années
avec la construction de ferme solaire
sur nos délaissés autoroutiers
concernant APA nous avons déjà d'ores et
déjà cinq fermes solaires en activité
qui produisent près de 30 mégawatts
crête nous en avons quatre en travaux et
une vingtaine en projet
il y a aussi un élément important pour
des carbonner les autoroutes c'est un
sujet de technologie du péage il s'agit
de passer progressivement d'un pH
classique à un pH en flux libre comme
c'est le cas sur la première autoroute
en service sur un 79 entre mon Marault
dans l'Allier et Digoin en
Saône-et-Loire
je pense que nous pouvons effectivement
imaginer de développer cette technologie
sur l'ensemble de réseau autoroutiers
avec un enjeu très fort d'économie
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes en train de chiffrer les
économies de d'émission au niveau du
secteur mais on peut d'ores et déjà
parler de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de tonnes par an qui seraient
économisés en passant le réseau en flux
libre
en tout cas
il y a une vraie réflexion à mener sur
les aires de services je pense qu'il
faut imaginer d'ores et déjà de les
reconfigurer complètement il est clair
que si le parc de véhicules légers
continue ça son évolution vers
l'électrique les stations que nous avons
mis en place depuis le début de l'année
c'est-à-dire entre 6 et 8 bornes de
recharge par R ne sera pas suffisant il
faut d'ores et déjà imaginer de passer à
des pôles de recharge sur nos aires de
services c'est-à-dire une trentaine
voire une quarantaine de bords
électriques et donc ça supposera des
investissements significatifs à élaborer
une petite question était posée sur sur
la 65 entre Pau et Langon donc c'est la
société concessionnaire Aliénor mais bon
effectivement nous ne sommes pas à
l'objectif de trafic qui était fixé au
moment de la mise en place de cette de
cette concession mais ça je dirais que
c'est les parties des risques et périls
du concessionnaire mais je veux juste
corriger un point le contribuable n'a
jamais été mis
à contribution sur cette autoroute
d'ailleurs comme sur toutes les
autoroutes de France puisque comme il a
été dit répéter à plus de reprise nous
sommes dans un système
d'utilisateurs payeurs et je pense que
c'est c'est beaucoup plus juste et
beaucoup plus logique et c'est surtout
beaucoup plus favorable pour en France
nous sommes un des pays les plus
traversés en Europe et il est tout à
fait intéressant que tant les véhicules
légers que les poids lourds étrangers
contribuent fortement à la modernisation
et au développement de notre réseau
voilà donc
voilà et en complément je reviens sur le
développement de de l'électrique
Philippe nourrit à mentionné les
investissements très importants et qui
ont été faits et je redis ce que j'ai
dans le premier propos liminaire
aujourd'hui c'est le réseau autoroutier
français qui est le mieux équipé pour
que circuler en électrique très très
au-delà de ce qui existe sur le réseau
de les réseaux nationaux non concédés
les réseaux départementaux afin
d'accompagner d'ailleurs on parlait de
tarif tout à l'heure afin d'accompagner
le développement de l'électrique le
groupe SANEF et je crois le groupe ap2r
qu'on sent aussi une réduction de 5% sur
l'ensemble des trajets réalisés en
véhicule électrique de manière à aussi a
aussi accompagner accompagner l'électro
mobilité
voilà ce que je voulais rajouter
si vous le permettez monsieur le
Président un point sur sur l'avenir des
contrats question qui a également été
posée donc après 2031 après 2031 2035
bon d'abord j'espère et je pense que
nous serons partis prenantes des assises
de l'autoroute que le ministère que le
ministre des Transports souhaite mettre
en place pour discuter du de ce sujet
bon l'état décidera mais vous ne serez
pas surpris que nous sommes convaincus
de l'intérêt du modèle de la concession
de la concession à la française les
avantages ont été évoqués transfert de
l'intégralité des risques au
concessionnaires ça va faire reconnu et
démontré des concessionnaires privés et
grandes capacité d'investissement pour
moderniser le réseau et améliorer la
dessert des territoires donc bon Arnaud
Camard en a parlé il faudra sans doute
adapter les contrats en termes de
contenu avec sans doute l'introduction
d'une certaine dose de régulation et des
clauses régulières de revoyure
poursuivre la rentabilité réelle et
l'adapter si besoin alors non pas qu'il
ait des problèmes dans les contrats
actuels mais cela permettra d'éviter en
tout cas les soupçons et les fausses
polémiques qui reviennent intervalles
réguliers il faudra aussi sans doute
réduire la durée
mais pas trop car les futurs
concessionnaires auront besoin d'une
visibilité
suffisante pour leur permettre de bien
s'organiser et surtout de réaliser de
rentabiliser leurs investissements nous
sommes actuellement sur 30 ans on
pourrait être sur 20 à 25 ans et ça a
été également dit il faudra sans doute
revoir le périmètre des concessions pour
les rendre un peu plus Modènes et
peut-être prévoir de raisonner plus en
itinéraires c'est à dire d'intégrer dans
le périmètre des concessions
des sections autoroutières qui sont
gérées aujourd'hui par l'État
en prolongation directe de nos réseaux
et à proximité des grandes villes des
sections sur lesquelles nous pourrions
remettre un niveau le patrimoine mettre
en place les nouvelles mobilités et
améliorer
l'insertion environnementale
donc le vrai sujet c'est de trouver une
meilleure solution de gestion
sous forme d'une concession retravaillée
et avec des acteurs privés
merci pour vos réponses nous continuons
dans les différentes questions des
collègues avec une question de
Jean-Pierre tête
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
en préambule en préambule vous dire que
je préfère rouler sur les autoroutes
françaises que sur les a autobanes de
nos amis allemands la qualité étant
incomparable mais beaucoup l'ont dit
dans cette commission le modèle des
contrats de concession démontre ainsi sa
pertinence en termes d'investissement et
de fonctionnement c'est d'ailleurs assez
surprenant d'écouter les leçons de ceux
qui n'ont jamais rien géré dans leur vie
qui n'ont jamais créé un centime de
richesse dans leur vie professionnelle
pour leur pays mais dont les indemnités
sont payées par l'argent public je
rappelle que les 6 milliards de la
réalisation du dernier tronçon de la 89
qui traverse ma circonscription dans la
Loire a été portée par le système de la
doucement qui consiste à faire financer
la construction d'une infrastructure par
les recettes générées par l'ensemble du
réseau vous l'avez dit la décarbonation
des routes est un impératif avec un coût
estimé de 60 à 70 milliards selon les
experts vous avez exposé beaucoup de
point un point parmi d'autres le nombre
de bornes de recharge est insuffisant
comparé au million qui serait nécessaire
en 2035 comment est à quel rythme
envisagez-vous un déploiement massif
quel type de borne envisagez-vous ces
investissements vont-ils avoir un effet
d'éviction sur les financements plus
traditionnels pour améliorer le réseau
je vous remercie ici la parole est à
Nicolas
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
une clause décontraques qui ont été
négociées en 2015 prévoyait une
indexation des péages sur l'inflation ce
qui a expliqué l'augmentation de 4,75%
en février dernier aujourd'hui la RT
juge préférable de renoncer à ses
clauses ou de la
recalibrer autrement je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment sur cela
je voulais vous interroger sur la
déclaration du ministre matin sur les
ondes mais vous y avez répondu et je
comprends que vous réservez votre
réponse simplement que pensez-vous de la
pertinence de faire bénéficier cette
ristourne au seul bénéficiaires de
chaque vacance comme l'an dernier est-ce
que c'est le bon critère et puis enfin
donc je suis député de l'Allier vous
avez évoqué le l'autoroute en flux libre
le premier autoroute en flux libre je
suis interpellé régulièrement par des
usagers qui n'ont pas encore l'habitude
de ce type de système de péage parfois
notamment les
usagers locaux qui n'ont que quelques
centimes ou quelques euros à régler
qu'envisagez-vous pour améliorer la
compréhension de ce système par ces
usagers merci la parole est à Vincent
des cœurs merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les présidents Monsieur le
Directeur général à la date de la fin de
des concessions devraient être constaté
le bon état de retour et de vos
appartiendra de démontrer à l'état que
les investissements prévus ont bien été
réalisés
vous évoquez régulièrement des
indicateurs qui en attestent je
souhaiterais que puissiez nous indiquer
si ces indicateurs auxquels vous faites
référence ont été définies en
concertation avec l'État et une deuxième
question ne pensez-vous pas que dans le
contexte qui entoure cette question des
conséquences des concessions pardon un
contexte de défiance on a pu le voir ce
matin ne serait-il pas judicieux de
confier d'évaluation des investissements
à un tiers sauf à ce que ce soit déjà
prévu
merci la parole est à Jean-Yves Bonnie
merci monsieur le Président et messieurs
merci tout d'abord pour vos propos et
aux éclairages et même si le Cantal est
quasiment dépourvu de structure
autoroutières Aurillac restant à la
préfecture la plus enclavée de France
permettez-moi d'évoquer le plan de
relance autoroutier 2015 ce plan
négociait à l'époque par le ministre de
l'écologie et le ministre de l'Économie
Emmanuel Macron ce plan avait négocié
une prolongation de trois ans des
concessions en échange de 3,2 milliards
de travaux les clauses de ces contrats
relativement défavorables à l'état ne
fut reconnu qu'en 2019
par qui ces clauses ont-elles été
suggérées lors de la négociation
vous aurez conduit à augmenter les
péages pour lisser votre rentabilité
comme le prétend la RT concernant la
clause de compensation de toute
augmentation de fiscalité ou de tout
abandon de rose de péage aviez-vous
attiré l'attention des deux mini sur les
implications de ces engagements pour la
parole de l'État merci merci la parole
est à Madame Christelle PETEX levée
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
merci d'avoir déjà pour tous les
éléments que vous nous avez exposés ce
matin et je serai donc brève la RT a
récemment préconisé des contrats plus
courts de l'ordre de 20 ans sur des
aires géographiques moins étendues
qui semble susciter votre adhésion
d'ailleurs seriez-vous enclin à renoncer
à la clause de stabilité sur la
fiscalité spécifique qui a pourri vos
relations avec l'État concédant y
compris jusque devant les tribunaux
pensez-vous que les démarches du
gouvernement pour aboutir à une fin
anticipée des contrats actuels
une clause de résiliation dans
d'éventuelles futures contrats vous
paraît-elle envisageable le recours à la
soulte plutôt qu'à des avenants
successifs allongeant la durée des
contrats vous paraît-il pertinent je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à Dino signorique
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
présidents Monsieur le Directeur Général
vous venez de nous communiquer l'avenir
des concessions autoroutières le modèle
français concessif reste perfectible
mais rendre les autoroutes gratuites en
les faisant peser sur les contribuables
et non sur les usagers serait en effet
injuste je suis régulièrement alerté par
les habitants de mon département de la
Loire qui déplorent les hausses
importantes du coup des péages première
question comment garantir une stabilité
des tarifs dans les années qui viennent
deuxième question monsieur Copé VINCI
Autoroutes a annoncé le blocage du prix
des péages de la majorité des trajets de
moins de 30 km et 10% de réduction sur
les recharges électriques sur 60000
bornes je profite de cette audition pour
attirer votre attention sur une
proposition de loi que je viens de
déposer pour imposer qu'au moment de
recharger le véhicule le prix est TTC en
euros du kilowatt-heure apparaît sur
l'écran ran de la borne de recherche et
qu'à la fin le montant total du plein
est effectué apparaissent également ce
qui n'est pas le cas actuellement est-ce
que ce sera bientôt le cas sur vos
bornes merci merci la parole est à Éric
Poget
oui merci président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Copé président de
Vinci Autoroutes mon département les
Alpes-Maritimes est traversé par la 8
qui est géré par Escota or sur l'ouest
du département l'autoroute aujourd'hui
apparaît comme un réel barrage par
rapport à la problématique des
inondations depuis une dizaine d'années
malheureusement avec le dérèglement
climatique on a été victime de
d'inondation violente et récurrente et
il y a un sujet aujourd'hui important au
sein de notre département notamment sur
le bassin Cannes gras Antibes ou des
discussions des négociations des études
avancées entre collectivités
territoriales services de l'État et vos
services sur des aménagements pour
prévenir ces problématique cette
problématique d'inondation or au moment
de la signature du contrat DSP c'est
travaux ne pouvaient pas être prévus
mais la réalité des faits c'est que
aujourd'hui le ces inondations sont
régulières je veux savoir où en sont vos
réflexions au sein du groupe Vinci par
rapport à ces aménagements attendus et
qui sont des aménagements de sécurité
par rapport à des bassins entiers de
population merci merci
déjà parlé ta madame Dubié Muller
Monsieur Merci monsieur les présidents
Monsieur le Directeur général le rêve de
rendre toutes les autoroutes gratuites
ou d'électrifier tout le parc de
véhicules implique forcément
l'assèchement des recettes de péage et
de TI CPE reste alors l'hypothèse d'une
modulation tarifaire en fonction des
émissions de CO2 comme le préconise la
directive Eurovignette ou les modes de
transport écologique tels que les
voitures propres ou le covoiturage
serait avantagés voire même financé par
un malus appliqué aux autres usagers
moins vertueux ou aux poids lourds
notamment étrangers cette discrimination
vous semble-t-elle viable à droit
constant permettra-t-elle de dégager des
ressources suffisantes pour financer la
construction et l'entretien des réseaux
ainsi que d'autres modes de transport
comme le ferroviaire cette logique
pollueur-payeur est-elle adaptée
concernant les véhicules légers la fin
des contrats en cours pourrait enfin
signifier à pH constant et sans
investissement ni remboursement de la
tête des recettes considérables pour les
éventuelles concessionnaires et pour
l'État concernant via la fiscalité
pensez-vous pertinent de miser sur
potentiels recettes pour emprunter
massivement dès aujourd'hui les fonds
requis pour l'amélioration des
transports voir la décarbonation des
autoroutes comme cela a déjà été proposé
merci merci la parole est à Gérard le
seul
merci Président Monsieur vous vous avez
rappelé quelques quelques évidences sur
les mobilités partagées sur les énergies
renouvelables sur la décarbonation enfin
c'est bien nous partageons d'ailleurs
ces constats mais nous vous encourageons
à multiplier les initiatives car les
mesures actuelles nous semblent
insuffisantes alors vous nous avez dit
que vous étiez des entreprises privées
dont acte et que vous ne répondiez pas
aux politiques publiques autre que celle
décidait dans dans le contrat de
concession vous considérez que vous êtes
d'ailleurs dans les clous initiaux tout
en reconnaissant que de nouveaux
contrats devraient être sans doute
retravaillés mais pardonnez-moi mais
vous contestez les conclusions des
différents rapports et cette
contestation systématique franchement
nous est apparu un peu agaçante en tout
cas pour ma part et aussi agaçante
d'ailleurs que les approches terribles
actionnaires vous ont agacé dans ces
rapports et vous donner de fait des
arguments parfois pour que nous ne
recondusions pas ce modèle de concession
je pose la question que plusieurs
collègues ont déjà posés à laquelle vous
n'avez pas encore répondu qu'êtes-vous
prêt à faire pour les automobilistes cet
été il n'y a pas que le ministre qui
vous pose la question
et enfin chers collègues la parole est à
Jean-Louis Bricout si je n'ai oublié
personne merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur
un peu de localisme d'abord je prends
l'autoroute tous les lundis soirs pour
me rendre à Paris par la 1 tout en des
travaux interminable à quand une
modulation des tarifs par rapport à un
service qui est pas rendu au final et je
confirme ce que disait Guy une fois
qu'on a passé le péage l'autoroute est
coupée et là c'est la galère pour
arriver à l'Assemblée avec un fléchage
insuffisant un autre un autre problème
mais un autre problème aussi enfin il y
a des conséquences quand même et puis
sur le parquet des des camions qui peut
présenter des problèmes de sécurité
parce qu'il est complètement insuffisant
sur cette portion de la pour revenir sur
le tarif des péages moi aussi je suis
très attentif effectivement à la réponse
que vous ferez au ministre sur sa
proposition de ce matin et puis sur un
trajet autoroutier on a aussi d'autres
sur coût surcoût sur le carburant des
surcos sur la restauration sur le petit
café qu'on a envie de prendre comment
vous vous intégrez en fin de compte
c'est surcoût dans vos sur profits si
c'est pas un gros mot pour vous et qui
profite en fin de compte de ces surcoûts
est-ce que c'est les enseignes de
restauration au final est-ce que c'est
les distributeurs d'énergie comment vous
pouvez agir sur ces tarifs pour arriver
des choses raisonnables
messieurs je vous laisse le soin de
répondre
assez question
je vous en prie
alors
je vais commencer
par la dernière je vais commencer
puisque ça me concerne directement
la première chose c'est effectivement
une fois qu'on a passé le péage on
arrive sur le les autoroutes de l'État
donc donc je ne suis pas comptable de je
ne suis pas comptable des travaux qui
sont réalisés sur le sur le sur les
autoroutes de l'État ce que je peux vous
assurer c'est que nous faisons nos
meilleurs efforts pour être en contact
avec les services de l'État et et donner
l'information la plus adéquate pour
éviter ce type de ce type de désagrément
ça c'est une chose ensuite sur en ce qui
concerne les airs et les coûts et les
produits sur les airs je pense que le
groupe SANEF met ainsi que ainsi que ses
collègues parfois avec des solutions
différentes nous avons nous effectuons
une une pression et aussi par des
dispositifs contractuels sur la
modération tarifaire la modération
notamment des carburants donc nous avons
un tiers de nos airs qu'on appelle les
aires bons plans sur lequel on a des
tarifs de carburant qui sont
particulièrement ajuster et à quelques
centimes de la moyenne des carburants
nationaux donc ça c'est elles sont
clairement clairement identifiées de la
même façon sur un certain nombre de
produits essentiels la bouteille d'eau
le café on fait en sorte sur sur nos
aires d'avoir des produits au pli les
plus ajustés et avec un service qui est
différent puisque on est sur les aires
d'autoroute avec une obligation de
service 24 heures sur 24 avec du
personnel et fortement ça ça rend
gérissement sur le sur le coup d'un
certain nombre de produits mais je peux
vous assurer que nous nous ajustons le
service de nos airs aux besoins nos
clients et notamment à ceux qui
recherchent les prix les plus ajustés
les plus ajustés possibles il y a une
autre question qui a été posée qui est
une question importante sur le bon état
d'entretien en fin de en fin de
concession alors je vais y répondre
parce que d'abord le groupe SANEF et la
concession SANEF et la première qui qui
s'arrête donc je peux témoigner du fait
que d'abord l'état d'entretien je t'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure et l'état de
l'infrastructure fait l'objet de
surveillance permanente et d'indicateurs
et d'indicateurs qui sont contractuels
donc c'est à dire vous votre question
était de savoir s'ils ont été négociés
avec l'État ou discuter avec l'État
évidemment c'est même même plus que ça
c'est l'État lui-même et le concédant
qui a fixé le niveau de ces indicateurs
au passage au fur et à mesure des
différents avenants l'État ne cesse de
remonter le niveau attendu de ces
indicateurs qui qui sont à niveau
extrêmement élevés et je les dis tout à
l'heure aussi je le répète nous sommes
conformes voire très largement conforme
aux indicateurs qui ont été qui ont été
faits en ce qui concerne la concession
SANEF qui donc la première à se terminer
en 2031 nous avons d'ores et déjà
contractualisés le bon état d'entretien
en fin de concession il y a une annexe
une nouvelle annexe qui est dans notre
contrat de concession qui précise les
détails techniques et les niveaux
techniques attendus sur les grands
objets de la concession qui sont à la
fois les chaussées et les ouvrages d'art
et donc ça c'est une chose qui a été
contractualisée dans le contrat de
concession il est prévu il était déjà
prévu depuis longtemps que sept ans
avant la fin de la concession donc on
s'y approche en ce qui concerne sa nef à
un audit est fait et la fixation d'un
programme de travaux est réalisé ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que les services
de l'État ont d'ores et déjà commencé ce
travail il nous avons d'ores et j'ai
commencé à travailler avec les services
de l'État sur à la fois je l'ai dit par
là une contractualisation mais aussi des
travaux techniques sur le bon état
d'entretien la qualification du bon état
d'entretien et à échanger notamment sur
toutes nos politiques d'entretien d'ici
la fin de la concession donc tout ça
dans ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
un esprit de Total transparence nous
travaillons total transparence avec les
services de l'État et avec un niveau de
contrôle réalisé soit par notre
concédant mais aussi par des pas des
autorités indépendantes qui est
extrêmement élevé voilà ce que je
voulais dire sur ce sujet
je voudrais maintenant répondre à
Monsieur pocher notamment sur la
question sur la 8
c'est une question très importante
je récuse l'idée que l'autoroute se
comporte en barrage
hydraulique nous avons
fait beaucoup d'investissements pour la
transparence hydraulique des ouvrages en
revanche la question que vous posez pose
la question
du programme dit de résilience
c'est-à-dire comment adapter et on
commence à rentrer enfin dans des sujets
qui concernent l'avenir et qui concerne
les réalités concrètes auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés la résilience
climatique on y est confronté au
quotidien on a eu non pas sur la 8 cette
fois mais sur la 9 au mois de septembre
dernier
la proximité de Nîmes un épisode d'une
ampleur milleniale d'eau qui a emporté
la chaussée on a eu plusieurs épisodes
sur la 8 on a vu l'autoroute A10 coupé
il y a quelques années par le
débordement de la retraite de la même
façon les infrastructures sont souvent
confrontées dans le désormais à des
épisodes de feu et à des incendies très
nous occupants il y a un contestablement
besoin de consentir des investissements
importants d'adaptation des ouvrages de
façon à assurer leur résilience et de
façon à ce que à la fois sur le plan
hydraulique ou sur la protection contre
le feu pourquoi pas également sur les
questions sismiques qui sont
particulièrement présents dans votre
région les investissements soient soit
fait je salue la remarque de Monsieur
tête sur le le rôle de la 89 dont nous
avons fêté les 10 ans de mise en service
le
mois dernier où il y a deux mois à
Tarare et dont le bilan économique et
social est brillant à la fois sur le
niveau d'activité le niveau de desserte
le niveau d'emploi l'impact sur le le
chômage et c'est important aussi de
rappeler que la de desserte des
autoroutes se mesure aussi en bilan
économique et social beaucoup des
questions qui ont été posées monsieur le
Président dans cette deuxième salve qui
s'agisse de l'inflation ou de la clause
de stabilité fiscale repose la question
de la manière dont est calculée
l'équilibre économique des concessions
ou de la manière dont a été calculé leur
valorisation au moment de la
privatisation des des sociétés je
voudrais sur l'inflation dire que nous
sommes évidemment
impactés de façon très significative par
l'inflation à la fois sur nos coûts
d'exploitation sur nos coups de
financement et sur nos coûts et c'est la
raison pour laquelle l'état des 1995 a
jugé
via le décret de 95 nécessaire d'indexer
à 70% de l'inflation les tarifs les
tarifs autoroutiers
mesure et pérenne elle fait partie de
l'équilibre économique des contrats elle
a fait également partie de leur
valorisation sur le père a maintenant
lorsque vous me parlez du plan de
relance autoroutier de de 2015
l'allongement moyen des concessions
consenties en contrepartie des 3,2
milliards d'investissements qu'il
prévoit et de deux ans et demi c'est
selon les sociétés je rentre pas dans
les détails s'il y a une chose qui est
sûr c'est que ce plan n'a eu aucun
impact sur les tarifs puisque par
définition quand on allonge les
concessions les concessionnaires sont
payés des recettes additionnelles de
l'allongement c'est-à-dire que ils font
le pari que l'allongement de la
concession entre 2034 et 2036 leur
donnera entre 2034 et 2036 de quoi
financer les investissements qu'ils font
entre 2015 et 2020 ce qui est à peu près
l'équilibre de ce qui a été calculé et
en effet lorsqu'on 2015 a été signé le
protocole sur le plan de relance
autoroutier il y avait un ensemble de
mesures essentiellement des mesures
d'investissement mais les
concessionnaires alors que venaient
d'avoir lieu un long débat sur la
compensation de la hausse de la
redevance de manière on demandait une
clause de stabilité fiscale spécifique
dont la logique est assez facile à
comprendre on calcule un équilibre
économique
avec des investissements et des recettes
dans un cadre de pression fiscale donnée
si la fiscalité change elle modifie
l'équilibre économique tel qu'il a été
calculé et compte tenu de la durée de
nos investissements nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le risque de variation fiscale
très significative si
alors même que nous avons calculé notre
équilibre économique dans un dans un
cadre donné c'est la raison de ce modèle
qui prévaut d'ailleurs dans toutes les
concessions c'est à dire que c'est pas
la nouveauté c'est pas c'est pas une
innovation c'est quelque chose qui a
toujours accompagné les engagements
économiques des concessionnaires et vous
rendez compte que compte tenu des
montants engagés il est indispensable
qu'on soit dans un cadre fiscal clair
sans quoi l'état reprendrait d'un côté
ce qu'il a accordé de l'autre comme
compensation reprendre ré d'une main ce
qu'il a accordé comme comme compensation
voilà ce que je pouvais dire je crois
que Philippe a un mot à ajouter
au députés Ray sur la 79 dans l'Allier
bon effectivement le CET autoroute est
la première équipée en flux libre donc
il peut y avoir un côté perturbant pour
un certain nombre d'usagers qui
découvrent cette technologie qui
n'existe pas ailleurs sur le réseau
autoroutier français mais les choses
vont évoluer progressivement la 13
devrait passer progressivement flux
libre les entrées d'Area en Rhône-Alpes
également donc on est engagé dans un
mouvement
qui va dans le bon sens sur cette
nouvelle technologie qui apporte plus de
fluidité plus de sécurité et surtout des
économies d'émission de CO2 par rapport
au pH traditionnel bon nous étions
conscients de la difficulté pour pour
l'Allier nous avons mis en place
un très gros dispositif de communication
avant l'ouverture avant la service en
novembre 2022 et encore aujourd'hui
quelques mois quelques mois plus tard
bon nous nous poursuivons nos efforts je
tiens quand même à vous rassurer la très
très grande majorité des
usagers de la 79
règles le pH par badge nous avons
développé donc
la mise à disposition de badge pour
notre clientèle ou pour abonnement
plaque d'immatriculation puisque les
plaques sont reconnues par le dispositif
et pour ceux qui ne voudraient ni payer
en badge ni payer en plaques on a mis à
disposition des bandes de paiement sur
les aires de repos de manière régulière
tout au long du trajet avec du personnel
de la concession pour aider les
usagers qui seraient en difficulté donc
les choses vont évoluer progressivement
nous sommes conscients de des
difficultés mais je pense que dans les
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent les choses seront rétablies
pour ce qui concerne le les efforts
éventuels sur le plan commercial à faire
pour l'été bon nous allons rencontrer le
ministre dans les troupes prochains
jours et vous comprendrez que nous ne
pouvons pas vous donner de réponse à ce
stade sur la question nous avions fait
un geste l'an dernier par
l'intermédiaire des chefs vacances donc
on va on va on va se concerter avec le
ministre et en parler entre nous pour
étudier cette question
je voudrais simplement
je voudrais simplement dire que le
financement par la concession des
Autoroutes du Sud de la France
je voudrais dire que le financement par
la concession des Autoroutes du Sud de
la France du contournement ouest de
Montpellier n'est pas une magouille mais
un décret en Conseil d'État que ce
décret en Conseil d'État est valable
qu'il est en cours d'application et que
nous travaillons et que nous
retravaillons actuellement à la demande
du Conseil d'État les gares
d'application de la hausse tarifaire qui
permettront de financer les 380 millions
d'euros d'investissements que ces
travaux représentent
pour ce qui me concerne un petit
complément sur le prix des carburants
sur sur nos autoroutes vous avez évoqué
cette cette question bon nous avions
constaté effectivement que les prix de
carburants étaient
plus chers que les prix de carburant de
ville on va dire et donc nous avons
décidé il y a quelques années de mettre
en service des stations de carburant sur
nos aires de service
qui sont directement gérés par le
concessionnaire donc par APRR sous la
marque fully nous avons d'ores et déjà 6
heures de service fully nous en aurons
une quinzaine d'ici quelques années
Césaire permettent de proposer à nos
clients des prix voisins des prix de
carburant qui sont proposés en ville
l'idée c'était effectivement de faire
pression sur ces prix d'autoroute qui
donnaient une impression de cherté sur
l'autoroute et l'objectif est rempli
puisque depuis quelques années le groupe
Total a mis en place des stations Total
accesso a mis en place des stations Esso
express et donc le nid globalement le
niveau de prix des carburants sur
autoroute a baissé de manière sensible
ces dernières années
messieurs merci pour les éléments de
réponse à porter vous avez compris la
volonté de notre commission de continuer
à investiguer sur ces sujets en tout cas
je pense que cette audition a permis
d'éclairer les députés de cette
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire